Hello everyone and we have some unbelievably exciting news for you all. Tom, if anything, you are underselling it because this is truly spectacular. On the 4th and 5th of July this year, we are going to be hosting the inaugural. Rest is History Festival. Out of all places, Hampton Court Palace. And crucially, this is just for the people who mean most to us. That is the members of the Rest is History Club. Tom, am I right?
大家好，我们有一些令人难以置信的激动人心的消息要告诉大家。汤姆，如果你说得太保守了，因为这简直太壮观了。今年7月4日和5日，我们将举办首届“历史就是一切”节（Rest is History Festival）。地点就在汉普顿宫。最重要的是，这仅面向对我们最重要的人，也就是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的成员。汤姆，我说得对吗？
You are so right, Dominic. So if you want to access tickets for the festival, then you will need to become a member of the Restis History Club, which is so easy to do. All you have to do is go to therestoshistory.com and it's a matter of seconds. Okay, so remember, by becoming a member of the Restis History Club, you will be able to enter that much prized ballot for tickets to this thrilling festival. But of course, on top of that, you'll get all our episodes ad-free. You will get early access to our epic series.
你说得太对了，多米尼克。所以，如果你想获得音乐节的门票，你需要成为“历史就是一切”俱乐部的会员，这非常简单。你只需要访问therestishistory.com，几秒钟就能搞定。好的，请记住，成为“历史就是一切”俱乐部的会员，你将有机会参与那张备受追捧的音乐节门票抽签。当然，除此之外，你还能收听我们所有无广告的剧集，并提前收看我们史诗般的系列节目。
will get weekly bonus episodes. You will get access to our exciting new exclusive mini-series. Most of all, you'll get an entree to our much love chat community and many more such exciting benefits. So if you want guaranteed access to two tickets, you can join the very top tier of the club and become an Athelstan. You will also get the exclusive opportunity to upgrade to a VIP ticket, which includes a range of special perks including, and this is so exciting, unlimited food and unlimited drink. So go to the rest is history.com and sign up immediately. It is going to be the most extraordinary weekend. There will be talks, there will be thrilling special guests, there will be historically themed music, there'll be all kinds of treats, there'll be all kinds of action,
你将获得每周的奖励剧集，还能观看我们激动人心的新独家迷你剧。最重要的是，你将进入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，并享受更多令人兴奋的福利。所以，如果你想确保获得两张门票，你可以加入俱乐部最高等级，成为一名“埃塞尔斯坦”（Athelstan）。你还将获得升级为VIP门票的独家机会，其中包括一系列特别礼遇，最令人兴奋的是，可以无限量享用美食和饮品。所以，请立即访问therestishistory.com并注册。这将是一个非凡的周末。届时会有讲座、激动人心的特邀嘉宾、历史主题音乐，还有各种各样的款待和活动。
there might even be some battles, but above all, it's all. All, it's a bit of all. It'll be a time for friendship, to get to know your fellow members and to get to know Tom and me in a very, very special place, Hampton Court Palace. And I know that I speak for Dominic as well as for myself when I say, we cannot wait to see you there. With the approach of Muhra, we are about to begin the month of epic heroism and self-sacrifice. This is the month blood will triumph over the sword.
甚至可能还有一些战斗，但最重要的是，这一切都是为了友谊，为了让你结识其他会员，并在汉普顿宫这样一个非常非常特别的地方了解汤姆和我。我知道，当我说我们迫不及待地想在那里见到你们时，我不仅代表我自己，也代表多米尼克。随着穆哈拉姆月的临近，我们将开启这个史诗般的英雄主义和自我牺牲的月份。这是鲜血战胜利剑的月份。
The month truth will condemn falsehood for all eternity. The month that has taught generations throughout history the path of victory over the bernet. The month the tyrants will be judged
这是真理将永远谴责虚假的月份。这是历史上教导几代人战胜暴政之路的月份。这是暴君将受到审判的月份。
and the satanic government abolished. This month will be famous throughout history. The month the powerful will be broken by the word as a right. The month that the Imam of the Muslims will show us the path of strength against the tyrants. The month the freedom fighters and patriots will clinch their fists and win against tanks and machine guns. When Islam is in danger, you should unite.
撒旦政府将被废除的月份。这个月将在历史上闻名。这是强者将被正义之言击垮的月份。这是穆斯林伊玛目向我们展示对抗暴君的力量之路的月份。这是自由战士和爱国者将紧握拳头，战胜坦克和机枪的月份。当伊斯兰教处于危险之中时，你们应该团结起来。
rise and sacrifice your blood. So that, of course, was this year's King's speech. It was Charles III addressing the nation. No, it wasn't really. That was the Ayatollah Roula Khomeini. And Dominic, it was a pivotal moment in the story of the Islamic Revolution because he drafted that, not in Najaf, in Iraq, where he'd been in our previous episode, but in Paris, the French capital, in November the 1978.
奋起并献出你们的鲜血。所以，那当然就是今年的国王演讲。那是查尔斯三世在向全国发表讲话。不，其实不是。那是阿亚图拉·鲁霍拉·霍梅尼。多米尼克，这是伊斯兰革命故事中的一个关键时刻，因为他起草那篇演讲时，并不是在我们上一集提到的伊拉克纳杰夫，而是在1978年11月的法国首都巴黎。
And this message was the one that triggered the final uprisings that led to the downfall of the Shah of Iran and paved the way for the triumphant return from exile of the Ayatollah Khomeini a few weeks later. So an incredibly dramatic moment. An incredibly dramatic moment. One of the defining moments in world history in our lifetimes, I would say. It's the moment that catapulted radical Islam into the headlines and completely transformed the Middle East. East. We'll come back to that message and the context of that message later in the episode. But let's just remind people of our story of our three principal characters. So last time we introduced the Shah, the second member of the Parvenu Palavi dynasty. He's been in charge
正是这条信息引发了最终的起义，导致了伊朗沙阿的倒台，并为几周后阿亚图拉·霍梅尼从流亡中凯旋归来铺平了道路。这是一个极其戏剧性的时刻。这是一个极其戏剧性的时刻。我认为这是我们有生之年世界历史上最具决定性的时刻之一。正是这一刻，激进的伊斯兰教登上了头条新闻，并彻底改变了中东。我们稍后会在本集中回到那条信息及其背景。但让我们先提醒大家我们故事中的三位主要人物。上次我们介绍了沙阿，巴列维王朝的第二位成员。他自1941年以来一直掌管
of Iran since 1941. He's been spending his oil winnings to modernize Iran and to try and turn it into a regional superpower. But he's seen on the streets as an American puppet. He's a corrupt man, a repressive man, but also a weak man, as we will discover. And that's a terrible combination, is it, to be both repressive and weak. Exactly. Be repressive and strong, I think, is the ideal combination, Tom. That's the Sanbrook way. So then you have the Ayatollah Khomeini, so this elderly cleric, who has been an exile in Iraq
伊朗。他一直把石油收入花在伊朗的现代化建设上，试图将其变成一个地区超级大国。但在街头，他被视为美国的傀儡。他是一个腐败的人，一个压迫者，但正如我们将要发现的那样，他也是一个软弱的人。这真是一个可怕的组合，既压迫又软弱。确实。我认为，既压迫又强大才是理想的组合，汤姆。这就是桑布鲁克（Sanbrook）的方式。那么，还有阿亚图拉·霍梅尼，这位自60年代中期以来一直流亡在伊拉克的年长神职人员。
since the mid-60s. He is learned. He is austere, formidable, a ferocious critic of the Shah's modernisation and secularisation drive and of the corruption of his court. And of course, a massive beard. Yes, a huge beard. And then a stranger to a beard, who is the US president, Jimmy Carter, who is another parvenu, actually, another outsider in the halls of power.
他博学、严谨、令人生畏，是沙阿现代化和世俗化运动及其宫廷腐败的猛烈批评者。当然，还有一把巨大的胡子。是的，一把巨大的胡子。而另一位对胡子很陌生的人是美国总统吉米·卡特，他实际上也是一个暴发户，是权力殿堂里的另一个局外人。
So he's from Plains, Georgia, and he is this strange combination of Christian evangelical, of southern populist, and a kind of technocratic micromanager. So like the Itola, he loves God. He does love God, yes, but in his own way, I think it's reasonable to say. say. Now, so far, Carter has enthusiastically backed the Shah, as did his American predecessors. Like his predecessors, he sees Iran as a key piece in the jigsaw of the American anti-communist alliance system, not least because detente is over and people are talking about a second cold war with the Soviet Union. But the question for Carter, which we ended the last episode, as the revolution on the streets of Iran
他来自佐治亚州的平原镇，他是基督教福音派、南方民粹主义者和某种技术官僚式微观管理者的奇怪组合。所以像阿亚图拉一样，他热爱上帝。是的，他确实热爱上帝，但我认为可以合理地说，是以他自己的方式。现在，到目前为止，卡特像他的美国前任一样，热情地支持沙阿。像他的前任一样，他将伊朗视为美国反共联盟体系拼图中的关键一块，尤其是因为缓和政策已经结束，人们正在谈论与苏联的第二次冷战。但对于卡特来说，正如我们在上一集结尾时所说，随着伊朗街头的革命
gather strength, is he going to stick with the regime or is he going to twist? So, Dominic, we left the story in the autumn of 1978. And since that point, you've had a cycle of demonstrations, of riots, of repression, gathering momentum. It's a classic story of a revolution, isn't it? I mean, it's basically it's the story that we visited with our series on the French Revolution. And as in the French Revolution, you have this kind of coalition of groups who have lost faith with the regime. So in Tehran, you have the people who are called the bazaaris, the kind of urban shopkeepers. and merchants and artisans.
力量不断增强，他是要坚持支持这个政权，还是改变立场？所以，多米尼克，我们将故事留在了1978年的秋天。从那时起，你经历了一系列示威、骚乱和镇压，势头不断增强。这是一场革命的经典故事，不是吗？我的意思是，这基本上就是我们在法国革命系列中探讨过的故事。正如在法国革命中一样，你有一群对政权失去信心的人组成的联盟。在德黑兰，你有被称为“巴扎里”（bazaaris）的人，即城市店主、商人和工匠。
Petit bourgeoisie. Petit bourgeoisie, who are alienated by the massive inflation caused by the oil boom. You have all these thousands upon thousands of young men, rural migrants who have moved to the big cities and feel alienated left behind. You have tens of thousands of university students who are chafing on what they see as the repression of the Shah's secret police. And those are the classic ingredients of a 20th century revolution. But the one ingredient that you don't get in other revolutions
小资产阶级。小资产阶级，他们因石油繁荣引发的巨大通货膨胀而感到疏远。你有成千上万的年轻人，那些搬到大城市并感到被遗弃、被抛在后面的农村移民。你有成千上万的大学生，他们对沙阿秘密警察的镇压感到愤怒。这些都是20世纪革命的经典要素。但你在其他革命中得不到的一个要素
is the fact that there are also Shiite clerics, Islamic clerics, who feel undermined both ideologically and economically by the Shah's modernisation programme. Exactly right, exactly. And all of this has gathered pace since the cinema wrecks fire on the 19th of August when 500 people burned to death, probably caused by Islamic militants, but blamed on the Shah's secret police.
是什叶派神职人员，即伊斯兰神职人员，他们感到在意识形态和经济上都受到了沙阿现代化计划的破坏。完全正确，完全正确。自8月19日电影院大火导致500人烧死以来，这一切都在加速，这很可能是由伊斯兰激进分子造成的，但却被归咎于沙阿的秘密警察。
What has made it all worse is the Shah has conspicuously failed to follow a strong line. in dealing with the demonstrations. So he has neither appeased the crowds nor cracked down and cleared the streets. Partly, I think, because he is ill with leukemia. So he cuts an increasingly listless and unhappy and disengaged figure.
更糟糕的是，沙阿在处理示威活动时明显未能采取强硬路线。所以他既没有安抚群众，也没有进行镇压并清理街道。部分原因我认为是因为他患有白血病。所以他表现得越来越无精打采、不快乐且心不在焉。
And his generals have been begging him. There is a story of a general falling on the ground in tears, basically clutching his knees and saying to him, please give us the green light to just go. in and clear the streets and do what needs to be done. And the Shah said, I am not a tyrant, despite what people say, I will not preside over a massacre. And do you think that had the Shah given the green light, things might have been different? Well, this is the question. Michael Axworthy in his book, Revolution in Iran, says, even if the Shah had not been ill,
他的将军们一直在恳求他。有一个故事说，一位将军泪流满面地跪在地上，紧紧抓住他的膝盖说，请给我们开绿灯，让我们进去清理街道，做该做的事。沙阿说，尽管人们这么说，但我不是暴君，我不会主持一场大屠杀。你认为如果沙阿开了绿灯，情况会有所不同吗？嗯，这就是问题所在。迈克尔·阿克斯沃西（Michael Axworthy）在他的《伊朗革命》一书中说，即使沙阿没有生病，
what would he have done? Where is the magic wand that would have sorted things out? Because it's quite like Bashar Assad in Syria, isn't it? I mean, he came down hard and the whole Syria just disintegrated into decades of terrible civil war. Would that have happened in Iran, possibly? There are examples. I was trying to think of examples where it works. A famous example, a very bloody one, is Indonesia in the mid-1960s, the world's biggest Muslim country, by the way.
他会怎么做？有什么魔杖能解决这些问题吗？因为这很像叙利亚的巴沙尔·阿萨德，不是吗？我的意思是，他采取了强硬手段，整个叙利亚就陷入了长达数十年的可怕内战。这会在伊朗发生吗？有可能。我试着想一些有效的例子。一个著名的、非常血腥的例子是1960年代中期的印度尼西亚，顺便说一下，那是世界上最大的穆斯林国家。
There, the military and its allies with American support killed, I think half a million people. Many communists and people on the left killed them all. And then it held power for the next, what, 30 years or so? Tiananmen Square. Teanaman Square. I mean, repression can work, right? It's not a lesson that people like to, you know, it's not something we like to tell ourselves.
在那里，军方及其盟友在美国的支持下，杀害了我想有五十万人。许多共产主义者和左翼人士被杀。然后它又掌权了大约30年？天安门广场。天安门广场。我的意思是，镇压是可以奏效的，对吧？这不是人们喜欢，你知道，这不是我们喜欢告诉自己的事情。
We like to tell ourselves the people would always triumph, but repression can work. So maybe it could have worked, I don't know. The Shah made one last effort to recapture the initiative on the 5th of November. He brought in an emergency military government, and he made an unprecedented TV broadcast to apologize to the people. He said, I'm so sorry about the oppression and corruption that you suffered under my incompetent ministers of old. Nothing to do with me. Yeah, of course. But he says, I have heard the voice of your revolution.
我们喜欢告诉自己人民总是会胜利，但镇压是可以奏效的。所以也许它本可以奏效，我不知道。沙阿在11月5日做了最后一次努力，试图夺回主动权。他引入了一个紧急军事政府，并进行了前所未有的电视广播，向人民道歉。他说，对于你们在我那些无能的老部长统治下所遭受的压迫和腐败，我深表歉意。与我无关。是的，当然。但他又说，我听到了你们革命的声音。
And once this is all over, you will have free elections and all sorts of reforms and all of this. Now, this is a classic pattern. If he'd said this two or three years earlier, people would have said, gosh, how enlightened and progressive the Shah is. But now they say, it's too little too late. And there's actually lots of rioting that night following his speech. and the US embassy reports to Washington that banks and hotels and things in Tehran and Tabarees and other cities are ablaze. So now the Americans have a big dilemma. As we saw last time, they have always struggled to work out what's going on in Iran and they haven't really got a clear strategy.
一旦这一切结束，你们将进行自由选举和各种改革等等。现在，这是一种经典的模式。如果他早两三年这么说，人们会说，天哪，沙阿是多么开明和进步。但现在他们说，太少、太晚了。事实上，在他演讲的那天晚上发生了大量的骚乱，美国大使馆向华盛顿报告说，德黑兰、大不里士和其他城市的银行、酒店等都在燃烧。所以现在美国人面临一个巨大的困境。正如我们上次看到的那样，他们一直难以弄清楚伊朗发生了什么，而且他们并没有真正制定出明确的策略。
Can I just ask, even by this point, have they fathomed the fact that actually for lots of the protesters against the Shah, it's slightly more than just saying, well, we'll have elections or we'll have reforms, that this is, fundamentally a theological opposition is brewing that can't be resolved by the kind of the tried and tested routes of democratic or secular politics. Have they figured that out, I think absolutely unequivocally the answer to that is no, because if you read, you can read online, you can read the texts of their cables and of their internal memos and all of this kind of thing, and there's very little mention of that. It's constantly kind of rearranging the deck chairs on the deck of the Titanic kind of stuff.
我能问一下吗，即使到了这个时候，他们是否已经明白，实际上对于许多反对沙阿的抗议者来说，这不仅仅是说“我们要选举”或“我们要改革”，而是从根本上说，一场神学上的反对派正在酝酿之中，无法通过民主或世俗政治的常规途径来解决？他们弄明白了吗？我认为毫无疑问答案是否定的，因为如果你阅读，你可以在网上阅读，你可以阅读他们的电报和内部备忘录以及所有这些东西，几乎没有提到这一点。这就像是在泰坦尼克号的甲板上重新摆放躺椅一样。
Now, Jimmy Carter, already out of his depth in Washington, according to lots of people on Capitol Hill and kind of Washington insiders, is totally out of his depth in kind of Middle Eastern foreign policy. I mean, before he was president, he was governor of Georgia. You know, nothing in his life has prepared him.
现在，吉米·卡特在华盛顿已经力不从心了，据国会山和华盛顿内部人士的许多人说，他在中东外交政策方面完全力不从心。我的意思是，在他担任总统之前，他是佐治亚州州长。你知道，他生命中没有任何经历为他做好准备。
And also, he's changing his foreign policy, even as this is going on, because he's moving from detenteeunt to hawkishness towards the Soviet Union. So there's no clarity at the top. But an equally big problem, As so often in Washington, there was a massive turf war going on to control American foreign policy. And Carter had institutionalized this in a way that's very familiar to people who study American administrations
而且，即使在这一切发生的同时，他也在改变他的外交政策，因为他正在从缓和政策转向对苏联的鹰派立场。所以高层没有明确的方针。但同样大的问题是，正如华盛顿经常发生的那样，为了控制美国的外交政策，一场巨大的地盘争夺战正在进行。卡特以一种研究美国政府的人非常熟悉的方式将此制度化了
by basically appointing two different people to run its foreign policy, and they will play a part in this series. So one of them is the Secretary of State Cyrus Vance. Dominic, can I just say, it's mad he's called Cyrus. I mean, that's not a good sign to the Ayatollah, is it? Cyrus is the first of the great Persian king. and the Shah's personal hero. So Cyrus Vance is the ultimate patrician wasp. He went to boarding school.
基本上任命了两个人来负责其外交政策，他们将在本系列中发挥作用。其中之一是国务卿赛勒斯·万斯（Cyrus Vance）。多米尼克，我能说一下吗，他叫赛勒斯真是太疯狂了。我的意思是，这对阿亚图拉来说不是一个好兆头，对吧？赛勒斯是伟大的波斯国王中的第一位，也是沙阿的个人英雄。所以赛勒斯·万斯是典型的贵族盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒（WASP）。他上过寄宿学校。
He went to Yale. He's very good at ice hockey, wasn't he? Yeah, he's a kind of sporty, you know. He'd wear a barber jacket now if he was around. And he'd wear a jiele if he was British. Definitely he would. He's the classic insider. He worked for Kennedy and Johnson.
他上过耶鲁大学。他冰球打得很好，不是吗？是的，他是一个运动型的人，你知道。如果他现在还在，他会穿巴伯（Barbour）夹克。如果他是英国人，他会穿吉列（gilet）。他绝对会。他是典型的内部人士。他曾为肯尼迪和约翰逊工作。
He was profoundly affected by Vietnam, which he came to oppose. So he's cautious and dovish and sort of suave and elli. Now, the other bloke is the National Security Advisor. You'll be delighted to see his name looming on their notes. Very Scrabble-friendly name. Yeah. So he's Zabignyv Brzeensky. And he's Polish-born, born in Warsaw.
他深受越南战争的影响，后来他开始反对这场战争。所以他谨慎、温和，而且文雅、圆滑。现在，另一个人是国家安全顾问。你会很高兴看到他的名字出现在他们的笔记上。非常适合拼字游戏的名字。是的。他是兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基（Zbigniew Brzezinski）。他是波兰裔，出生在华沙。
He's a foreign policy realist. He is tough. He is hawkish. He is, you know, very hard on Russia, as you would expect, because of his Polish background. He's kind of mates with Henry Kissinger. He's very much cut from Kissinger's cloth. And since the first day of the administration, Cyrus Vance and Zabignyip Brasinski have been fighting for Carter's ear. And by late 1978, there's basically this undeclared feud going on between the two of them.
他是一位外交政策现实主义者。他很强硬。他是鹰派。正如你所料，因为他的波兰背景，他对俄罗斯非常强硬。他算是亨利·基辛格的伙伴。他很大程度上是基辛格那一派的。从政府成立的第一天起，赛勒斯·万斯和兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基就一直在争夺卡特的青睐。到了1978年底，他们两人之间基本上已经爆发了一场未公开的争斗。
The State Department on the one side, the National Security Council on the other, and they're both fighting for influence. I mean, it's a very common thing in American administrations, frankly. So they're massively dithering in Washington. The Shah's inert because he's got his illness and he doesn't know what to do. And that means the initiative has really passed to the third of our principal characters, who is the forbidding figure of the Ayatollah. And we left him in Najaf, in Iraq, from where his supporters have been smuggling in these tapes of his sermons. Now, the Iraqis, the people who run Iraq, are not keen on the Ayatollah.
一边是国务院，另一边是国家安全委员会，他们都在争夺影响力。我的意思是，坦率地说，这在美国政府中是非常普遍的事情。所以他们在华盛顿极其犹豫不决。沙阿因为生病而无所作为，他不知道该怎么办。这意味着主动权已经真正转移到了我们三位主要人物中的第三位，也就是阿亚图拉这位令人敬畏的人物手中。我们把他留在了伊拉克的纳杰夫，从那里，他的支持者一直在走私他的布道录音带。现在，伊拉克人，那些管理伊拉克的人，并不喜欢阿亚图拉。
They've tolerated him being there all this time as a sort of little, you know, as a little sort of gesture of spite towards their Persian. and neighbours. But they are Ba'athists. So the Ba'ath party are Arab nationalists, they're socialists, and they're relatively secular. And Ba'athism has been the fashionable cause of the 1950s and 1960s in the Arab world. But also, Dominic, crucially, the Ba'ists by this point are almost exclusively Sunni, and the Sunnis are a minority in Iraq. So I think Iraq is about 60, 65% Shia. And so that's another complication.
他们一直容忍他待在那里，作为一种对他们的波斯邻居的恶意姿态。但他们是复兴党人。所以复兴党是阿拉伯民族主义者，他们是社会主义者，而且相对世俗。复兴党主义是1950年代和1960年代阿拉伯世界流行的事业。但多米尼克，至关重要的是，到这个时候，复兴党人几乎全是逊尼派，而逊尼派在伊拉克是少数。所以我认为伊拉克大约60%到65%是什叶派。所以这是另一个复杂因素。
And obviously, in the long run, will be an element in the terrible war that Iran and Iraq will end up fighting throughout the 80s. Exactly. Now, the big folk in Iraq at this point is the vice president, a very familiar name, Saddam Hussein. And Saddam Hussein, you know, because he's a bathist, because he's a secularist, because he's a Sunni, all of these. he thinks, why are we having this mad bloke, you know, this Ayatollah?
显然，从长远来看，这将成为伊朗和伊拉克在80年代最终进行的那场可怕战争的一个因素。完全正确。现在，伊拉克此时的大人物是副总统，一个非常熟悉的名字，萨达姆·侯赛因。萨达姆·侯赛因，你知道，因为他是复兴党人，因为他是世俗主义者，因为他是逊尼派，所有这些。他想，我们为什么要留着这个疯子，这个阿亚图拉？
Why do we tolerate him? So eventually, in September 1978, he kicks the Ayatollah out. And Khomeini at first wants to go to Kuwait or to Syria. The Kuwaiters won't have him. The Syrians won't have him. And some of his kind of acolytes say to him, this is mad, but why not go to the West? Because actually, although, you know, you hate the West,
我们为什么要容忍他？所以最终，在1978年9月，他把阿亚图拉赶走了。霍梅尼起初想去科威特或叙利亚。科威特人不要他。叙利亚人不要他。他的一些追随者对他说，这太疯狂了，但为什么不去西方呢？因为实际上，虽然你讨厌西方，
if you went to the West, you'd have much more freedom. No one would interfere with you. you'd have complete access to the world's press, and it'd be dead easy for you to broadcast your message. You know, what better place? And so he says, okay, fine. And on the 6th of October, 1978, while all these protests are going in Iran,
如果你去了西方，你会拥有更多的自由。没有人会干涉你。你将完全接触到世界媒体，广播你的信息会非常容易。你知道，还有什么比这更好的地方吗？所以他说，好吧，没问题。1978年10月6日，当伊朗发生所有这些抗议活动时，
hominy flies to Paris, and he's settled in a small town west of Paris called Neuf Le Chateau, this little town, took a house, and he becomes, for the first time, really, a massive international celebrity. So the European media, who have now become interested in Iran, is starting to make the headlines. This bloke turns up in Paris, who to them seems like, he's like it's coming a time machine from the Middle Ages. Yeah, because, you know, a cleric with a massive beard and black robes in Iran or Iraq isn't news.
霍梅尼飞往巴黎，他在巴黎西部的一个小镇诺夫勒沙托（Neuf-le-Château）定居下来，这个小镇，租了一栋房子，他第一次真正成为了一个巨大的国际名人。所以现在开始关注伊朗的欧洲媒体开始登上头条。这个家伙出现在巴黎，对他们来说，他看起来就像是从中世纪坐时光机来的。是的，因为你知道，在伊朗或伊拉克，一个留着大胡子、穿着黑袍的神职人员并不是新闻。
But one at this point, outside Paris, absolutely is. And it is the incongruity, isn't it? It's imagine if you're a British newspaper. reader. You're living in a world where Larry Grayson is presenting the Generation Game and, you know, the sex pistols, they're past their prime. You know, this is the world that you live in. And suddenly on the front page of the newspapers, there's this bloke who's turned up in Paris with this big beard and he gets up at three o'clock in the morning and he fasts and he prays and he talks about sin and good and evil in the end of the world. You're like, wow, this guy's, this is wacky. This is fun. When I was in Iran, I went to this place, Hamadan. ancient Ekpatana and I met a guy who claimed that while he was in exile in Paris the Ayatollah got very into buying expensive French lingerie for his wife and I have no
但在这一点上，在巴黎郊外，绝对是新闻。这就是不协调感，不是吗？想象一下，如果你是一个英国报纸读者。你生活在一个拉里·格雷森（Larry Grayson）主持《世代游戏》（Generation Game）的世界里，你知道，性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols）已经过了他们的鼎盛时期。你知道，这就是你生活的世界。突然间，在报纸的头版上，出现了这个家伙，他出现在巴黎，留着大胡子，他在凌晨三点起床，他禁食、祈祷，他谈论罪恶、善恶和世界末日。你会想，哇，这家伙，这太古怪了。这很有趣。当我在伊朗时，我去了哈马丹这个地方。古老的埃克巴坦那（Ekbatana），我遇到一个人，他声称当阿亚图拉在巴黎流亡时，他非常热衷于为他的妻子购买昂贵的法国内衣，我完全
idea whether this is true I'm not I'm not convinced he was an entirely trustworthy informant but if there are any specialists in the Ayatollah's sex life out there let me know I mean I find that very implausible frankly I just want to distance myself from that from that rumour for the avoidance of doubt now within day of the Ayatolle arriving in Nufla Chateau, his house is surrounded by TV crews and reporters and so on, people demanding an audience. And this is, you know, we've described him
不知道这是不是真的，我不相信他是一个完全值得信赖的线人，但如果那里有任何关于阿亚图拉私生活的专家，请告诉我。我的意思是，坦率地说，我觉得这非常不可信。为了避免怀疑，我只想与那个谣言保持距离。现在，在阿亚图拉抵达诺夫勒沙托后的几天内，他的房子就被电视摄制组和记者包围了，人们要求觐见。这是，你知道，我们已经描述过他
as a medieval throwback. You know, it's like he's arrived in a time machine. But actually, in many ways, he is a very modern media figure. Because in the few weeks that he's in Paris, he gives 130 separate interviews to the world's press. And this is Uttel, a sign, you know, it's easy to see him as a pantomime villain.
是一个中世纪的倒退。你知道，就像他坐时光机来的一样。但实际上，在许多方面，他是一个非常现代的媒体人物。因为在他待在巴黎的几周里，他接受了130次世界媒体的单独采访。这是一个信号，你知道，很容易把他看作一个哑剧反派。
particularly for Americans, for whom he did become a pantomime villain in 1979 and 1980. But he is more canny, I think, and more pragmatic in some ways, skillful, than people sometimes give him credit for. Because when he does these interviews, he uses speechwriters who are not religious conservatives, but are people who have been dissidents based in Paris, Iranian dissidents, who are more liberal, left-wing. secular, and they craft his message and they downplay his Islamism. Now, his Islamism is absolutely central, obviously. It's heartfelt. And it all comes down to a concept that he calls Valayat Afaki, which means the guardianship of the jurist. Now, this is going to be the basis for the Islamic Republic and the Islamic Revolution. So Tom, do you want to explain to people
特别是对美国人来说，他在1979年和1980年确实成为了一个哑剧反派。但他比人们有时给予他的评价更精明，我认为在某些方面更务实、更熟练。因为当他进行这些采访时，他使用的演讲稿撰写人不是宗教保守派，而是那些以巴黎为基地的异见人士，伊朗异见人士，他们更自由、左倾、世俗，他们精心制作了他的信息，并淡化了他的伊斯兰主义。现在，他的伊斯兰主义显然是绝对核心的。它是发自内心的。这一切都归结为一个他称之为“法基赫的监护”（Velayat-e Faqih）的概念，意思是法学家的监护。现在，这将成为伊斯兰共和国和伊斯兰革命的基础。所以汤姆，你想向人们解释一下
what this actually means? On the one hand, it is exceedingly conservative. So the Ayatollah, the clerical establishment in Iran, are deeply opposed to anything that smacks of Western-style legal innovations. So whether that is the concept of secularism, whether that's the concept of human rights or whatever, they see these as contrary to the law of God. And this law, in the opinion of the Shia jurists, among whom the Ayatollah is the leading figure, derives from various sources. So the Quran, of course, the sayings and practices of the Prophet and his family, the teachings of the various imams. So that's Ali Hussein, and there are 11 of them, and the 12th Imam the Mardi, is waiting to appear. There is also scope for independent reasoning, but this independent reasoning must be rooted in the kind of the classical texts of Shiite Islam. And this is centuries and centuries old
这到底意味着什么吗？一方面，它极其保守。所以阿亚图拉，伊朗的神职人员阶层，深切反对任何带有西方风格法律创新色彩的东西。所以无论是世俗主义的概念，还是人权的概念等等，他们都认为这些违背了上帝的法律。而在什叶派法学家看来，阿亚图拉是其中的领军人物，这种法律源于各种来源。所以当然是古兰经，先知及其家人的言行和实践，各位伊玛目的教导。所以那是阿里、侯赛因，总共有11位，第12位伊玛目马赫迪正在等待出现。也有独立推理的空间，但这种独立推理必须植根于什叶派伊斯兰教的经典文本中。这已经有几个世纪的历史了
And the Ayatollah is absolutely conscious of himself And proud of himself as the heir of this inheritance From the Golden Age of Islam And to quote Abbas Ammanat In Iran this had resulted in a fetishistic avoidance And frowning defiance of anything new novel and unfamiliar So on one level, the Ayatollah is what he seems to be A kind of bristling bearded, beetle-browed conservative
阿亚图拉绝对意识到自己，并为自己作为这种遗产的继承人而自豪，从伊斯兰黄金时代开始。引用阿巴斯·阿马纳特（Abbas Amanat）的话，在伊朗，这导致了一种恋物癖式的回避，以及对任何新的、新奇的和不熟悉的事物的皱眉反抗。所以在一个层面上，阿亚图拉就是他看起来的样子，一种竖着胡子、甲虫眉的保守派。
On the other hand, however, it is profoundly revolutionary. The Ayatollah is a deeply subversive figure in the context of Shiism, let alone in the context of the Shah's secular state. Because he is proposing something incredibly radical and novel. For the first time in Shiite history, the Ayatollah is proposing that clerics like himself should shoulder the Velaiat, which is the guardian. of the state, so as in Veliette E. Faki, that was supposed to have perished with Ali and Hussein. So we talked in the previous episode about how the attitude of the Shia jurists had always been one of, you know, any state is illegitimate. But they're now saying, no, we can shoulder this burden. We can run the state. You know, we're not going to wait for the Mardi.
另一方面，然而，它是深刻的革命性的。在什叶派的背景下，更不用说在沙阿的世俗国家的背景下，阿亚图拉是一个深刻的颠覆性人物。因为他提出了一些极其激进和新颖的东西。在什叶派历史上，阿亚图拉第一次提出像他这样的神职人员应该肩负起“监护”（Velayat），也就是国家的监护人，正如“法基赫的监护”一样，那本应随着阿里和侯赛因的去世而消失。所以我们在上一集中谈到了什叶派法学家的态度一直是如何的，你知道，任何国家都是非法的。但他们现在说，不，我们可以肩负这个重担。我们可以管理国家。你知道，我们不会等待马赫迪。
We are going to do it. So it is, I mean, it takes, it's a massive theological innovation. And I think what inspires the Ayatollah to do it is a genuine sense of himself as guided by God, and he in due course will come to be called an imam. So, you know, one of the lines of these imams. I think also it reflects desperation, a sense that if they're going to topple the Shah, they need something else to put in his place because the Ayatollah is anxious that otherwise it will lead to communist revolution or socialism, which in, I think, in the Ayatollah's eyes would possibly be even worse than monarchy.
我们要自己做。所以，我的意思是，这是一种巨大的神学创新。我认为激励阿亚图拉这样做的是一种真正的自我意识，即他受到上帝的指引，他最终将被尊称为伊玛目。所以，你知道，这些伊玛目中的一员。我认为这也反映了一种绝望，一种如果他们要推翻沙阿，他们需要别的东西来取代他的感觉，因为阿亚图拉担心否则会导致共产主义革命或社会主义，我认为，在阿亚图拉眼中，这可能比君主制更糟糕。
And I think ironically, there is also a hint of Western influence, or perhaps one might say Greek influence, because we mentioned how the Ayatollah's area of academic specialisation was Greek philosophy, and particularly Plato. And Plato had this idea of a state being run by, you know, enlightened experts. And you can see how that is something that could be reinterpreted by a Shiite philosopher. And I just also wonder, you know, he goes to, to, to, to, Paris to France, which is the home of
而且我认为具有讽刺意味的是，还有一丝西方影响，或者也许可以说希腊影响，因为我们提到阿亚图拉的学术专业领域是希腊哲学，特别是柏拉图。柏拉图有这种由开明的专家管理国家的想法。你可以看出这是一种可以被什叶派哲学家重新诠释的东西。我也在想，你知道，他去巴黎，去法国，那是
revolution against monarchy, perhaps just lurking in the background is an awareness of that, I don't know. So basically this idea of the guardianship of the jurist it means that for the first time in Iranian history, the clerics and their
反抗君主制的革命的发源地，也许背景中潜伏着对这一点的意识，我不知道。所以基本上，这个法学家监护的想法意味着在伊朗历史上第一次，神职人员和他们
interpretation of Sharia law will be the basis of the state. But actually what that means in practice at this point is very, very vague. And actually it's one of the beauties of the Ayatollah's idea of Islamic government is because the details aren't spelled out. Yeah, that's why it's so potent. Yeah, they can assume it'll be whatever they like. So he's got this idea that he's been developing all these years. But in the interviews in
对伊斯兰教法的解释将成为国家的基础。但实际上，在这一点上，这意味着什么是非常非常模糊的。事实上，阿亚图拉的伊斯兰政府理念的美妙之处之一就是细节没有被明确说明。是的，这就是它如此强大的原因。是的，他们可以假设它会是他们喜欢的任何样子。所以他有这个他多年来一直在发展的想法。但在巴黎的采访中，
Paris, he plays that down. So what he says to the Western interview is he says, look, I'm just a teacher, I'm just a scholar. I hate the Shah. I hate his corruption, as secret police. I think Iranians should be free to choose their own government. And people, a lot of the Western visitors say, what's not to like. You know, he seems that... He's a holy man. He's obviously not corrupt. He's not...
他淡化了这一点。所以他对西方采访者说的是，看，我只是一个老师，我只是一个学者。我讨厌沙阿。我讨厌他的腐败，他的秘密警察。我认为伊朗人应该有权选择他们自己的政府。人们，许多西方访客说，这有什么不好呢？你知道，他看起来……他是一个圣人。他显然不腐败。他不是……
You know, he's never been guilty of violence. What could possibly be bad about him? But I think there's also something that specifically appeals to people on the left, and particularly the anti-colonialist left, because the Iotaur is very keen on a Quranic phrase, the disinherited of the earth. And in translation,
你知道，他从未犯过暴力罪。他有什么不好的地方吗？但我认为还有一些东西特别吸引左翼人士，特别是反殖民左翼，因为阿亚图拉非常热衷于一个古兰经短语，“大地上的被剥夺者”。在翻译中，
this echoes very famous post-colonial phrase, the wretched of the earth, which is the title of France Fanon's book that came out in 1961 and is really the foundational text of kind of post-colonial theory. And he's against imperialism, right? He's against Western imperialism. So you're from the left. But when people on the left hear him talking about the disinherited of the earth, you know, it absolutely chimes with everything that they're reading.
这呼应了一个非常著名的后殖民短语，“大地上的受苦者”（The wretched of the earth），这是弗朗茨·法农（Frantz Fanon）1961年出版的书名，它确实是后殖民理论的基础文本。他反对帝国主义，对吧？他反对西方帝国主义。所以你是左翼。但当左翼人士听到他谈论“大地上的被剥夺者”时，你知道，这绝对与他们正在阅读的一切产生了共鸣。
There's a very famous example, a left-wing activist, Princeton professor called Richard Falk, who wrote about him in the New York Times. And he said, when the Ayatollah comes in, he may well provide a desperately needed model of humane governance for a third world country. Foucault was also a big fan, wasn't he? Yeah, this is the kind of commentary you get on him at this point. Now, the messages that Khomeini is sending back to Iran strike a very different note. And you read one of those, the most crucial one at the beginning of this episode,
有一个非常著名的例子，一位左翼活动家，普林斯顿大学教授理查德·福尔克（Richard Falk），他在《纽约时报》上写过关于他的文章。他说，当阿亚图拉上台时，他很可能会为第三世界国家提供一种急需的人道治理模式。福柯也是他的大粉丝，不是吗？是的，这就是你此时对他得到的评论。现在，霍梅尼传回伊朗的信息发出了非常不同的声音。你读了其中一条，在本集开头读了最关键的一条，
which was his jolly New Year message smuggled into Iran for the opening of Muharram. Now, Muharam is the first month in the Islamic calendar, and it's really important and holy for Shia. isn't it? Because it begins with nine days of mourning. And the 10th day is Ashura, which is the day that we talked about in the previous episode, which is the anniversary of the death of Hussein at the Battle of Kabul, which is seen as this kind of cosmic moment of disaster. Exactly. And so Homini sends this message, and he says, this is the month. This is the month that will be famous throughout history
那是他为穆哈拉姆月开端而走私到伊朗的快乐新年信息。现在，穆哈拉姆月是伊斯兰历的第一个月，对什叶派来说非常重要和神圣，不是吗？因为它以九天的哀悼开始。第10天是阿舒拉节，这是我们在上一集中谈到的日子，也就是侯赛因在卡尔巴拉战役中死亡的周年纪念日，这被视为一种宇宙灾难时刻。完全正确。所以霍梅尼发出了这个信息，他说，这就是这个月。这就是将在历史上闻名的月份，
when the freedom fighters will clench their fists and win. You know, when people should sacrifice their blood, he says, if you have to kill 5,000 people, 10,000 people, 20,000 people, do whatever it takes to bring down the Shah. And this rhetoric is revolutionary, but it's also apocalyptic. The language of blood and sacrifice is hardwired into Shiite thinking. And it strikes a massive chord because for the next nine days, for the first nine days of morning, there are thousands of people dressed in white mourning shrouds out on the streets. I mean, Western reporters watching this said
当自由战士将紧握拳头并获胜时。你知道，当人们应该牺牲他们的鲜血时，他说，如果你必须杀死5000人、10000人、20000人，不惜一切代价推翻沙阿。这种修辞是革命性的，但也是末日论的。鲜血和牺牲的语言深深植根于什叶派思想中。它引起了巨大的共鸣，因为在接下来的九天里，在前九天的哀悼中，有成千上万的人穿着白色的哀悼寿衣走上街头。我的意思是，观看这一幕的西方记者说
there were like an army of the dead or something. It was an extraordinary scene. All of these people dressed in white chanting against the Shah. There are nightly confrontations with the Shah's soldiers every evening. There are tanks and armoured cars in the streets. I mean, you talk about apocalypse, Tom.
他们就像一支死者大军之类的。这是一个非凡的场景。所有这些人穿着白衣，高呼反对沙阿的口号。每天晚上都有与沙阿士兵的对抗。街上有坦克和装甲车。我的意思是，你谈论末日，汤姆。
There's a massive sense of apocalyptic dread in December 1978 on the streets of Iran. And then, just as the Ayatollah had foreseen, the climax comes, on Ashura, so the night of the 10th into the 11th of December, which is your anniversary of the Battle of Cabela and 680. And basically what happens is the Shah's army seals off the kind of ceremonial core of the city, the palaces, the ministers, the embassies, and they abandon the rest of the city to the crowds. And there are some estimates that there are a million people in the streets chanting Magbar Shah,
1978年12月，伊朗街头有一种巨大的末日恐惧感。然后，正如阿亚图拉所预见的那样，高潮在阿舒拉节到来，也就是12月10日到11日的晚上，这是你提到的680年卡尔巴拉战役的周年纪念日。基本上发生的事情是，沙阿的军队封锁了城市的仪式核心，宫殿、部长、大使馆，他们把城市的其余部分留给了人群。据估计，街上有百万人高呼“打倒沙阿”，
Mark Bar, America, death to the Shah, death to America and all this kind of thing. Now, the fact that they're chanting death to America tells you that they think the Americans are the Shars. They're the embodiment of Westernization and secularism. They're the puppet masters. But the irony is if they are puppet masters, they are useless puppet masters. It's because they can't agree what to do. And we ended the last episode with Ambassador William Sullivan standing there in the U.S. Embassy. and thinking, this is a flipping nightmare.
“打倒美国”，所有这些东西。现在，他们高呼“打倒美国”的事实告诉你，他们认为美国人是沙阿的后台。他们是西方化和世俗主义的化身。他们是傀儡大师。但讽刺的是，如果他们是傀儡大师，他们也是无用的傀儡大师。因为他们无法就该做什么达成一致。我们在上一集的结尾是威廉·沙利文（William Sullivan）大使站在美国大使馆里，
It's all going to pieces. We're going to have to change horses. We should find out what the Ayatala wants. He doesn't like communism. We don't like communism. We can do a deal. Right, there's some middle ground. Let us build bridges with the Islamic clerics.
心想，这真是一场彻头彻尾的噩梦。一切都在分崩离析。我们必须换马了。我们应该找出阿亚图拉想要什么。他不喜欢共产主义。我们也不喜欢共产主义。我们可以达成协议。对，有一些共同点。让我们与伊斯兰神职人员建立桥梁。
We don't know anything about Khomeini. Come on. The window of time is closing. Let's sort this out. This goes down incredibly badly in Washington, especially with the hawkish national security advisor, Zabigny of Brzezinski. Brzezinski says to Carter,
我们对霍梅尼一无所知。拜托。时间窗口正在关闭。让我们解决这个问题。这在华盛顿引起了极大的反感，特别是对鹰派国家安全顾问兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基。布热津斯基对卡特说，
Your bloke in Tehran has totally lost his marbles. But the Shah is our man. We should stick with the Shah. Get the Shah to send in the troops. Clear the streets. Let's stop messing around. They have a showdown and the Oval Office on the 10th of December. Cyrus Vance, the patrician kind of boarding school guy.
你在德黑兰的人完全疯了。但沙阿是我们的人。我们应该坚持支持沙阿。让沙阿派兵。清理街道。别再胡闹了。他们在12月10日的椭圆形办公室进行了一次摊牌。赛勒斯·万斯，那个贵族寄宿学校出身的家伙。
He says, I think we should actually listen to Sullivan. He knows what he's talking about. He's my man from the State Department. Prisinski says, are you mad? You'd plot with some mad medieval fanatic against our own close ally. I've got to put this in the notes. It's an amazing story.
他说，我认为我们实际上应该听听沙利文的。他知道他在说什么。他是我的国务院的人。布热津斯基说，你疯了吗？你会和一个疯狂的中世纪狂热分子密谋反对我们自己的亲密盟友。我必须把这个写进笔记里。这是一个惊人的故事。
Brzezinski got an interview from Le Mans, translated and gave it to Carter. And Carter read it, and he sent it back with one word written in the margin. Nutty! This wasn't peanut diplomacy. Such a missed opportunity.
布热津斯基从《世界报》（Le Monde）得到了一篇采访，翻译后给了卡特。卡特读了它，并把它退了回来，在页边空白处写了一个词：疯子（Nutty）！这不是花生外交。真是错失良机。
This was his psychiatric diagnosis of the Ayatollah. And so Carter said, the Ayatollah is obviously a madman. Like, we can't do a deal with him. Now, Sullivan, when he heard the news, went mad in Tehran. and he sent off an incredibly insolent telegram back to Washington,
这是他对阿亚图拉的精神病诊断。所以卡特说，阿亚图拉显然是个疯子。就像，我们不能和他达成协议。现在，沙利文听到这个消息后，在德黑兰发疯了，
and he said Carter has made a gross and perhaps irretrievable mistake by failing to send an emissary to Paris to see Khomeini. I cannot repeat, cannot understand the rationale. I'm going to say it right now. Ambassador Sullivan was undoubtedly right. I think it is a colossal mistake from Jimmy Carter not to have sent an emissary to see Khomeini. Maybe Khomeini would still have ended up in power,
他发了一封极其无礼的电报回华盛顿，他说卡特犯了一个严重且可能无法挽回的错误，因为他没有派特使去巴黎见霍梅尼。我无法，不能理解其中的逻辑。我现在就要说，沙利文大使无疑是正确的。我认为吉米·卡特没有派特使去见霍梅尼是一个巨大的错误。也许霍梅尼最终还是会掌权，
and it would still have the Islamic Republic of Iran and whatever, but the Americans missed a window there. But if you have no understanding of the potential power that Islam and therefore the Ayatollah, as someone who is channeling the power of Islam has, you can understand why you would just say, well, he's nutty. That's what your ambassador is for. Your ambassador is there to get the temperature on the streets,
而且它仍然会有伊朗伊斯兰共和国之类的东西，但美国人错失了一个窗口。但如果你不了解伊斯兰教，以及因此作为传达伊斯兰教力量的人——阿亚图拉所拥有的潜在力量，你就能理解为什么你会说，好吧，他是个疯子。这就是你大使的作用。你的大使在那里是为了感受街头的温度，
to understand what's going on. I mean, Sullivan wasn't perfect, but he had a sense things are spiraling out of control. I accept that, but I'm just sticking up for Jimmy Carter here, that he doesn't know what he's dealing with. Okay, he definitely doesn't know what he's dealing with. Anyway, Carter wanted to sack Sullivan straight away.
去了解正在发生什么。我的意思是，沙利文并不完美，但他感觉到事情正在失控。我接受这一点，但我只是在为吉米·卡特辩护，他不知道自己在处理什么。好吧，他绝对不知道自己在处理什么。总之，卡特想立刻解雇沙利文。
And Cyrus Van said to him, we actually need to keep an ambassador and we can't be sacking our ambassador at this crucial moment. Anyway, the next day, Sullivan goes to the palace to see the Shah. And it's an extraordinary scene, a ghostly scene, the place is deserted. A lot of the Shah's courtiers have already fled abroad. they've been taking crates of furniture and jewelry and paintings and so on.
赛勒斯·万斯对他说，我们实际上需要留住一位大使，我们不能在这个关键时刻解雇我们的大使。总之，第二天，沙利文去皇宫见国王。那是一个非凡的场景，一个幽灵般的场景，宫殿空无一人。国王的许多朝臣已经逃往国外。他们带走了成箱的家具、珠宝、绘画等等。
They've been making bank transfers to the Cayman Islands or they're all gotten gains, all of this. But the Shah and Empress Farah are still there in this kind of marble prison of the palace, surrounded by mirrors, these sort of sad figures dining by candle-like as the power cuts. Sullivan goes in and he says to the Shah, look, we had a plan to contact Comini. I mean, you might not like it, but we did. And we've scrapped it. and the Shah is shocked because he has always believed, weirdly,
他们一直在向开曼群岛进行银行转账，或者他们所有的不义之财，所有这些。但国王和法拉赫皇后仍然待在宫殿这座大理石监狱里，被镜子包围着，这些悲伤的人物在停电时借着烛光用餐。沙利文走进去，对国王说，看，我们曾有一个联系霍梅尼的计划。我的意思是，你可能不喜欢它，但我们确实有。而且我们已经取消了它。国王很震惊，因为他一直奇怪地相信，
this thing about the Americans being puppet masters, he's believed it too. And he said, what, you don't have any plan? Sullivan said, we don't have any plan now, I'm really sorry. I mean, it's a classic example, isn't it, of the way in which actually conspiracy theories are a comfort blanket? It reassures you that somebody knows what's going on. You mean the British art masterminding this?
关于美国人是傀儡操纵者这件事，他也相信了。他说，什么，你们没有任何计划？沙利文说，我们现在没有任何计划，我真的很抱歉。我的意思是，这是一个经典的例子，不是吗？阴谋论实际上是一种安慰毯？它让你确信有人知道发生了什么。你是说英国人在幕后策划这一切？
It's a real disappointment. It is total anarchy. And Sullivan says in his memoirs, up to this point, the Shah had imagined that we had some grand design that was intended to save his country and perhaps somehow or other his dynasty.
这真是一个巨大的失望。这完全是无政府状态。沙利文在他的回忆录中说，直到这一点，国王还以为我们有一个宏大的设计，旨在拯救他的国家，也许以某种方式拯救他的王朝。
And it's like the scales fall from the Shah's eyes. It suddenly became clear to him as it had to me that we had no design whatsoever and that our government's actions were being guided by some inexplicable whim. So Sullivan, it was a bad day for both of us. I mean, it's a particularly bad day for the Shah. So events are now moving very quickly indeed.
就像国王眼中的鳞片脱落了一样。他突然变得清楚了，就像我一样，我们根本没有任何设计，我们政府的行动是被某种无法解释的突发奇想所引导的。所以沙利文，这对我们俩来说都是糟糕的一天。我的意思是，这对国王来说尤其糟糕。所以事件现在确实发展得非常快。
A lot of Americans have already left, but there are still 10,000 or so in Iran. But on the 23rd of December, the most senior oil executive in Iran, who was a guy called Paul Grimm, who actually managed and ran the oil fields. He was ambushed and shot by militants. He was the first foreigner to be killed in the revolution. And the oil companies at this stage say, okay, we're pulling the plug. We're getting the people out.
许多美国人已经离开了，但伊朗仍有大约一万人。但在12月23日，伊朗最高级别的石油高管，一个叫保罗·格里姆的人，他实际上管理和运营着油田。他被武装分子伏击并枪杀。他是革命中第一个被杀的外国人。石油公司在这一阶段说，好吧，我们不干了。我们要把人撤出来。
So they start getting their workers' families out. And by the end of December 1978, the oil fields of Iran, which are so central to the world's economy, have been pretty much completely shut down. So now, insanely, there is petrol rationing in Iran's cities. Iran, this oil-rich country has no oil for its own people. And in Europe, oil prices are going up daily. They've gone up by about 20%. So not good news for Jim Callahan.
所以他们开始把工人的家属撤出来。到1978年12月底，对世界经济至关重要的伊朗油田几乎完全关闭了。所以现在，疯狂的是，伊朗的城市里出现了汽油配给。伊朗这个石油资源丰富的国家竟然没有石油供自己的人民使用。而在欧洲，油价每天都在上涨。它们已经上涨了大约20%。所以这对吉姆·卡拉汉来说不是好消息。
Not good news. Although Britain is now, of course, about North Sea oil is about to come on stream for Britain. So oddly, Britain is one country that wasn't massively affected. Oh, well, that's a positive. Yeah. So we're the riguaners and all this. And on the last day of 1978, the Shah makes one final despairing effort to recapture the initiative. He sacks his military government.
不是好消息。当然，虽然英国现在北海石油即将投入生产。所以奇怪的是，英国是一个没有受到严重影响的国家。哦，好吧，那是个积极的一面。是的。所以我们是钻井工人，所有这些。在1978年的最后一天，国王做出了最后一次绝望的努力来夺回主动权。他解散了他的军事政府。
He brings in a new prime minister who is a moderate liberal dissident called Shapur Bakhtyar. He's the kind of person who a few years earlier, he'd have been a nice progressive hero with his lovely moustache. But now, you know, he's just a sort of Shah crony. And he's been left behind. He's the Korenski of the Iranian Revolution. Now, at this point, the Shah is already thinking, I'm probably going to have to get out. The next time he meets Sullivan, he says, I realize I'm going to have to go. And Sullivan says, where do you want to go?
他带来了一位新的总理，一位名叫沙普尔·巴赫蒂亚尔的温和自由派异见人士。他就是那种几年前会是一个留着漂亮胡子的进步英雄的人。但现在，你知道，他只是国王的一个走狗。他已经被抛弃了。他是伊朗革命的克伦斯基。现在，在这一点上，国王已经在想，我可能不得不离开了。下一次他见到沙利文时，他说，我意识到我不得不走了。沙利文说，你想去哪里？
And the Shah says, a terrible thing, actually. The worst thing he ever did. He says William Sullivan, I have a home in England, but I don't want to go there because the weather is so bad. But, I mean, that's great news for Britain, isn't it? Because it would actually have been terrible for him to come because... Do you know what? Jim Gallowhan, great friend of the rest of his history, he had already said he didn't want the show. Didn't want him to come.
国王说，实际上是一件可怕的事情。他做过的最糟糕的事情。他说威廉·沙利文，我在英国有一个家，但我不想去那里，因为天气太糟糕了。但是，我的意思是，这对英国来说是个好消息，不是吗？因为他来这里实际上会很糟糕，因为……你知道吗？吉姆·卡拉汉，我们历史其余部分的好朋友，他已经说过他不想要国王。不想让他来。
like George V, refusing Nicholas II. Yes. So Sullivan says to him, would you like to come to the United States? Would you like me to organise an invitation for you? And he said, the Shah lent forward like a little boy and said, oh, would you? So Sullivan reports back to him and says, I've got a place for you. Great publishing magnate and former ambassador to Britain, Walter Annenberg. He's got a house in Palm Springs, California, and he says you can have that.
就像乔治五世拒绝尼古拉二世一样。是的。所以沙利文对他说，你想去美国吗？你想让我为你组织一个邀请吗？他说，国王像个小男孩一样向前倾身说，哦，你会吗？所以沙利文向他汇报说，我为你找了个地方。伟大的出版大亨和前驻英大使沃尔特·安嫩伯格。他在加利福尼亚州的棕榈泉有一栋房子，他说你可以住那里。
I've been to it. Did you stay in it, though, Tom? I didn't stay in it. I was, but it was the Palm Springs Literary Festival, which I highly recommend. We had a little tour. Well, the Shah, he says, I'm going to go to Egypt first to see my mate, President Sadat, then I'll go from there to California. And Sullivan says, once they'd discussed this, and once the Shah had reconciled himself to it, he seemed relieved, even excited at the prospect. And it's interesting to think what would have happened had he ended up in California,
我去过那里。汤姆，你住过吗？我没住过。我当时在，但那是棕榈泉文学节，我强烈推荐。我们进行了一次小参观。好吧，国王说，我先去埃及见我的朋友萨达特总统，然后从那里去加利福尼亚。沙利文说，一旦他们讨论了这一点，一旦国王接受了这一点，他似乎感到宽慰，甚至对前景感到兴奋。想到如果他最终去了加利福尼亚会发生什么，这很有趣，
because California becomes the great bolthole, doesn't it, for lots of upper and middle class Iranians. So it really would have been a king in exile there, yeah. So the plan is put in motion. On the morning of Friday the 19th of January, the Shah and his Empress leave the palace for the last time. The guards, it's an amazing scene. The guards are all lined up, a lot of them in tears. They get on a helicopter. It's going to take them to Tehran Airport. It's a freezing cold and windy day.
因为加利福尼亚成了许多伊朗上层和中产阶级的避难所，不是吗？所以他真的会成为那里的流亡国王，是的。所以计划付诸实施。1月19日星期五早上，国王和他的皇后最后一次离开宫殿。卫兵们，这是一个惊人的场景。卫兵们都排成一列，许多人泪流满面。他们登上了一架直升机。它将带他们去德黑兰机场。那是一个寒冷多风的日子。
And as they look out of the helicopter, they can see these great lines of people waiting for emergency paraffin supplies. And these huge queues of cars outside petrol stations that are being held in line by troops firing automatic weapons in the air to stop people getting out of line. They get to the airport. It's totally deserted because the strikes have shut it down. There's just a row off upon row of Iran air planes standing there idle. And there's a little group of politicians and officers that have come to say farewell. There's this guy, the last prime minister, Shapur Bakhtiar, and the Shah says to him, I entrust Iran to you and to God. And he starts walking very stiffly towards the plane. And he's clearly trying to hold back the tears. Now, meanwhile, at exactly this moment,
当他们从直升机向外看时，他们可以看到人们排着长队等待紧急石蜡供应。加油站外有巨大的汽车队列，士兵们用自动武器向空中射击以阻止人们离开队列。他们到达了机场。那里完全荒无人烟，因为罢工已经关闭了它。那里只有一排排伊朗航空公司的飞机闲置在那里。有一小群政客和军官来告别。有这个家伙，最后一任总理沙普尔·巴赫蒂亚尔，国王对他说，我把伊朗托付给你和上帝。他开始非常僵硬地走向飞机。他显然在努力忍住眼泪。现在，与此同时，就在这一刻，
moment, news has reached the city. The Shah is fleeing. People are going berserk. They're blaring their kind of car horns. They're tearing down statues. They're tearing down street names. They are burning portraits. They're doing all this kind of thing. The Shah gets to the plain steps. And at this point, one of his generals, a very famous photograph, bends over to kiss his hand. The general is crying uncontrollably. And the Shah looks the way he can't look at him because he and his face, You can see in the photo, his face is this mask. It's absolutely stricken, but he's clearly trying to hold back the tears himself. And then he gets on the plane, and the plane lifts off, and it goes up into the sky.
消息传到了城市。国王正在逃跑。人们变得狂暴。他们狂按汽车喇叭。他们推倒雕像。他们撕掉街道名称。他们烧毁肖像。他们做着所有这些事情。国王走到飞机舷梯。在这一点上，他的一位将军，一张非常著名的照片，弯下腰去亲吻他的手。将军哭得无法控制。国王看着他，他不能看着他，因为他和他的脸，你可以在照片中看到，他的脸是一张面具。它绝对是痛苦的，但他显然在努力忍住自己的眼泪。然后他上了飞机，飞机起飞了，飞向天空。
And a few moments later, he has gone. The Shah of Shars has fallen, and the stage is set for the return of the Ayatollah. And the exciting news, Dominic, is that the Ayatollah will be returning after a commercial break. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. and we left you at Tehran Airport on the 19th of January, 1979. The Shah was disappearing on a plane into the sky. But Dominic, let's pick the story up 16 days later and head back to Tehran Airport
片刻之后，他走了。万王之王已经倒下，阿亚图拉回归的舞台已经搭好。令人兴奋的消息是，多米尼克，阿亚图拉将在商业广告后回归。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们把你留在了1979年1月19日的德黑兰机场。国王正消失在飞向天空的飞机里。但多米尼克，让我们在16天后重新开始这个故事，回到德黑兰机场
because someone now is arriving. Yeah, we haven't left. So it's the 1st of February, 1979. Another plane is coming into land, and this is a chartered Air France 747 from Paris. and the plane lands it taxes to a halt. This time there's a huge crowd. Massive crowd reporters, cameramen, airport staff.
因为现在有人要到了。是的，我们还没走。所以是1979年2月1日。另一架飞机正在降落，这是一架从巴黎包租的法国航空747飞机。飞机降落并滑行至停止。这一次有巨大的人群。大量的人群、记者、摄影师、机场工作人员。
You can see the clips online. The door opens. A French flight officer comes down the stairs and he's holding with his left hand. He's supporting this tall, gaunt figure behind him dressed entirely in black. And this is the Ayatollah Khomeini back on Iranian soil.
你可以在网上看到这些片段。门开了。一名法国飞行官走下楼梯，他用左手扶着。他支撑着身后那个身材高大、面容憔悴、全身黑衣的人物。这就是回到伊朗土地上的阿亚图拉·霍梅尼。
for the first time in 15 years. It is one of the great set pieces in 20th century history, comparable to Lenin at the Finland Station, one of these kind of Kennedy at the Berlin Wall, one of these kind of iconic moments. But the one person who's not moved by it is the Ayatollah. He is totally impassive, and very famously on the flight on the way over,
这是15年来第一次。这是20世纪历史上伟大的定场戏之一，可以与芬兰车站的列宁、柏林墙的肯尼迪相提并论，是这些标志性时刻之一。但唯一没有被它感动的人是阿亚图拉。他完全无动于衷，而且非常著名的是，在飞行的途中，
there were loads of journalists, and ABC's American reporter Peter Jennings, said to him, what are you feeling at this moment? And he said in Farsi, nothing. I have no feelings. And, you know, that's the I-Tol-a-T, right? You're not playing the game. You know, defying the expectations of the Western media, preserving this formidable, imperturbable, unflappability. You know, I feel nothing. You know, it's such a sort of powerful moment. Anyway, he gets into the airport building. There are a thousand clerics there. There's a huge banner. The flag of the revolution is in your hands. You are our leader. What no one knows is what that
有很多记者，美国广播公司的美国记者彼得·詹宁斯问他，你此刻有什么感觉？他用波斯语说，没有。我没有任何感觉。而且，你知道，这就是阿亚图拉，对吧？你不按套路出牌。你知道，无视西方媒体的期望，保持这种令人生畏、不可动摇的冷静。你知道，我什么感觉都没有。你知道，这是一个如此强大的时刻。总之，他进入了机场大楼。那里有一千名神职人员。有一条巨大的横幅。革命的旗帜在你们手中。你是我们的领袖。没有人知道那
means. But there is a hint straight away in the airport building when Khomeini addresses the crowds. And he says to them, our final victory will come when all the foreigners are out of the country. I beg God to cut off the hands of all evil foreigners and all of their helpers. I mean, that's a delightful way to pay back that French guy who'd helped him down the stairs. I think he would probably make an exception for him. That's good. Well, you know, does he mean it? I mean, actually, as we'll see later on, Khomeini was not always, you know, incredibly unfriendly to foreigners in Tehran.
意味着什么。但在机场大楼里，当霍梅尼向人群发表讲话时，立刻就有了暗示。他对他们说，当所有的外国人都离开这个国家时，我们的最终胜利就会到来。我祈求上帝切断所有邪恶外国人和他们所有帮凶的手。我的意思是，这是一种报答那个在楼梯上帮助他的法国人的绝妙方式。我想他可能会为他破例。那很好。好吧，你知道，他是认真的吗？我的意思是，实际上，正如我们稍后将看到的，霍梅尼并不总是对德黑兰的外国人非常不友好。
But a kind of nativism, I think, was a nationalism was always a key part of his appeal. Yeah, it's interesting, because on the flight over, he'd been asked, should we destroy Persepolis, the ancient city of the Persian kings? And he'd said no, because it's part of the glory of Iran. There's a nationalism to the Iranian revolution and to the Islamic Republic that I think is possibly sometimes overlooked by Western observers. They see it purely in terms of the Islamism of it. But the Iranian nationalism is, I think, a really important element. Well, the Shiite character of Iranian Islam, in a way, enables the nationalism
但我认为一种本土主义，我认为民族主义一直是他吸引力的关键部分。是的，这很有趣，因为在飞行途中，有人问他，我们应该摧毁波斯国王的古城波斯波利斯吗？他说不，因为那是伊朗荣耀的一部分。伊朗革命和伊斯兰共和国有一种民族主义，我认为有时会被西方观察家所忽视。他们纯粹从伊斯兰主义的角度来看待它。但我认为伊朗民族主义是一个非常重要的因素。好吧，伊朗伊斯兰教的什叶派特征，在某种程度上，使民族主义
and the Islamism to blend and blur. Exactly. So then he travels from the airport into the city, this unbelievable scene. I mean, he's in a Mercedes van and he is traveling along the streets. The streets are packed with people. There are people on the rooftops on balconies and hanging from cranes on every ledge, screaming and shouting. Le Monde estimated that there were 10 million people there.
和伊斯兰主义融合并模糊了。正是如此。所以他从机场前往城市，这令人难以置信的场景。我的意思是，他坐在一辆梅赛德斯面包车里，他正沿着街道行驶。街道上挤满了人。人们在屋顶上、阳台上，挂在起重机上，在每一个壁架上，尖叫和呐喊。世界报估计那里有1000万人。
I mean, how can you possibly tell? But there are undoubtedly millions, plural, and millions more watching on TV. I mean, it is one of the defining moments of Iranian history. And they stopped when they finally got to this huge cemetery in southern Tehran, the biggest cemetery in the city. And he gave another ferocious speech. The Shah destroyed our country and filled our cemeteries. His government are criminals. I shall appoint my own government.
我的意思是，你怎么可能数得清？但毫无疑问有数百万，复数，还有数百万人通过电视观看。我的意思是，这是伊朗历史上决定性的时刻之一。当他们最终到达德黑兰南部这个巨大的墓地时，他们停了下来，这是城里最大的墓地。他又发表了一次凶猛的演讲。国王摧毁了我们的国家，填满了我们的墓地。他的政府是罪犯。我将任命我自己的政府。
I shall slap this government in the mouth. Rebast. There's robust. Now, it's talking about what the Shah's government. Khomeini is returning to a country in total and utter chaos with a complete vacuum at the top. The Shah's last prime minister, Mr. Bactiar, is still supposedly running the country. Now, Bactear had tried to contact Hormény in Paris,
我要扇这个政府一耳光。粗暴。那是粗暴。现在，它谈论的是国王的政府。霍梅尼正回到一个处于完全混乱状态的国家，顶部有一个完全的真空。国王的最后一任总理巴赫蒂亚尔先生据称仍在管理这个国家。现在，巴赫蒂亚尔曾试图联系巴黎的霍梅尼，
and Khomeini had completely ignored him. Homani had said, your government is illegal, you're appointed by the Shah who's a bad man, you should quit, I don't care what you think about anything. When Khomeini announced that he was coming back, Bactiard tried to stop him by closing the airports. There were massive demonstrations,
而霍梅尼完全无视了他。霍梅尼说，你的政府是非法的，你是被国王任命的，他是个坏人，你应该辞职，我不在乎你怎么想。当霍梅尼宣布他要回来时，巴赫蒂亚尔试图通过关闭机场来阻止他。发生了大规模的示威，
the troops fired onto the crowds, they killed several dozen more people, and that was Bactiard basically tarnished forever, because he just looks like the Shah's puppet and another version of the Shah. So now, when Khomeini returns, Khomeini has the, he absolutely has the initiative,
军队向人群开火，他们又杀了几十人，那基本上让巴赫蒂亚尔永远蒙羞，因为他看起来就像国王的傀儡和国王的另一个版本。所以现在，当霍梅尼回来时，霍梅尼拥有，他绝对拥有主动权，
but no one knows what he will do. And to be honest, I actually don't think he knows himself what he will do, because he hasn't been in Iran for 15 years, but God will guide. He knows that God will guide,
但没有人知道他会做什么。老实说，我其实认为他自己也不知道他会做什么，因为他已经15年没去过伊朗了，但上帝会指引。他知道上帝会指引，
but what will God want him to do? Michael Axworthy, in his brilliant book on the early days of the revolution, says, you know, probably Khomeini thought, that he would end up being a kind of figurehead, a guardian for a regime in which there would be different elements shocking for power, or he just doesn't know, how can you know?
但上帝会想要他做什么呢？迈克尔·阿克斯沃西在他关于革命早期的精彩著作中说，你知道，霍梅尼可能认为，他最终会成为某种傀儡，一个政权的守护者，其中会有不同的力量在争夺权力，或者他只是不知道，你怎么可能知道？
Certainly a lot of his colleagues and a lot of the people that he works with in the first months of the revolution thought, he'll be there at the beginning, he'll be the standard bearer, he'll be the face of it, but over time he'll fade into the background. I mean, he's never had political power. He's never run anything, because that's she actually. clerics don't have power. It's unheard of the very idea of it. Yeah. At first, he sets up a revolutionary council at a girls' school in the city centre. Now, funny enough, this is exactly what the Bolsheviks did in 1917 at the Smolni Institute in Petrograd and other girls' educational
当然，他的许多同事以及他在革命最初几个月里共事的人都认为，他会在开始时在那里，他会是旗手，他会是它的门面，但随着时间的推移，他会淡出背景。我的意思是，他从未拥有过政治权力。他从未管理过任何事情，因为那是什叶派。神职人员没有权力。这闻所未闻，这个想法本身就是。是的。起初，他在市中心的一所女子学校建立了一个革命委员会。现在，有趣的是，这正是布尔什维克在1917年彼得格勒的斯莫尔尼学院和其他女子教育
establishment. So maybe this is an argument for outlawing girls' schools because they become hotbeds of revolution. I don't know. And he appoints his own rival prime minister, who actually is very like Mr. Bacti, he's a man called Medi Barsagan. Does he have a moustache? He does. He's got a moustache and a kind of little, very, so intellectuals mustache and beer, sort of goatee combinations. So not a full-throated one. Oh, no. He's another liberal dissident, kind of democratic dissident. And Medi Barsagan, you know, when he goes in front of the cameras, he says, you know, we're going to have an elected constituent assembly, we'll have a right to new constitution, we'll have democratic elections, all of this. It's very kind of European revolution. Because I guess at this point, at this point, at this point, those secularist revolutionaries against the Shah's government, whether they're the kind of centrist dads or whether they're the socialists or whether they're the communists,
机构所做的。所以也许这是一个取缔女子学校的论点，因为它们成了革命的温床。我不知道。他任命了他自己的竞争对手总理，他实际上非常像巴赫蒂亚尔先生，他是一个叫梅迪·巴扎尔甘的人。他有胡子吗？他有。他留着胡子，一种小小的，非常，所以知识分子的胡子和山羊胡组合。所以不是那种浓密的。哦，不。他是另一个自由派异见人士，某种民主异见人士。梅迪·巴扎尔甘，你知道，当他出现在摄像机前时，他说，你知道，我们将有一个民选的制宪会议，我们将有权制定新宪法，我们将有民主选举，所有这些。这非常像欧洲革命。因为我想在这一点上，在这一点上，在这一点上，那些反对国王政府的世俗革命者，无论是那种中间派父亲，还是社会主义者，还是共产主义者，
they think that they can use the Ayatollah. I think they undoubtedly do. Riding a crocodile and very soon will be swallowed up by it. There's a sort of, perhaps, an ominous hint for Mr. Barsigan at this press conference, because Khomeini is there, and Khomeini says, this isn't going to be an ordinary government. It's a government based on the Sharia.
他们认为他们可以利用阿亚图拉。我想他们无疑是这样认为的。骑在鳄鱼背上，很快就会被它吞噬。在这次新闻发布会上，对巴扎尔甘先生有一个不祥的暗示，因为霍梅尼在那里，霍梅尼说，这不是一个普通的政府。这是一个基于伊斯兰教法的政府。
Opposing this government means opposing the Sharia of Islam, a revolt against God, and revolt against God is blasphemy. You know, people can't say they weren't warned. And in Michael Axworthy's book, he says, these two elements of the revolution are always intention, not just in the early days, but actually throughout the history of the Islamic regime to the present. On the one hand, it's the Islamic Republic of Iran. You know, there is a kind of republican idealism.
反对这个政府意味着反对伊斯兰教法，是对上帝的叛乱，而对上帝的叛乱就是亵渎。你知道，人们不能说他们没有被警告过。在迈克尔·阿克斯沃西的书里，他说，革命的这两个要素总是处于紧张状态，不仅在早期，而且实际上在伊斯兰政权的整个历史中直到现在。一方面，它是伊朗伊斯兰共和国。你知道，有一种共和主义的理想主义。
But on the other hand, it's the Islamic. Yeah. So people do vote. There is a parliament. women can vote and they still can vote today, right? They have elections, they have competitions for offices. And yet at the same time, there is the Islamic foundation and the idea that opposing it is blasphemous
但另一方面，它是伊斯兰的。是的。所以人们确实投票。有一个议会。女性可以投票，她们今天仍然可以投票，对吧？他们有选举，他们有职位竞争。然而与此同时，有伊斯兰基础，以及反对它是亵渎的想法
and opposing Sharia law and all of that kind of thing. I mean, one of the amazing illustrations of the way in which if it's banned by the Sharia, then you can't do it. So, say, homosexuality would be banned. But there is nothing in the Sharia about sex changes. So Iran, I think, historically, it's the country where there's been the largest number of sex changes. Yeah, that's right. I know it is a really weird thing, isn't it?
以及反对伊斯兰教法等等。我的意思是，如果伊斯兰教法禁止，那么你就不能做，这方面的一个惊人的例子。所以，比如，同性恋会被禁止。但伊斯兰教法中没有任何关于变性的内容。所以伊朗，我认为，历史上，它是变性人数最多的国家。是的，那是对的。我知道这真是一件很奇怪的事情，不是吗？
Now, there is a potential threat to Khomeini's new order, and that is the army. I mean, always the issue, right? In revolutions, what's the army going to do? Carter had sent an American general, General Heiser, to encourage the Iranian generals to stand firm and to make plans for a coup. But they couldn't trust their own men. They've got thousands of conscripts who are precisely the kind of young working-class men who have been attracted to Homeni's message. These men start deserting. On a 10th of February,
现在，霍梅尼的新秩序面临一个潜在的威胁，那就是军队。我的意思是，总是这个问题，对吧？在革命中，军队会做什么？卡特曾派一名美国将军，海泽将军，鼓励伊朗将军们坚定立场并制定政变计划。但他们无法信任自己的人。他们有成千上万的应征入伍者，他们正是那些被霍梅尼的信息所吸引的年轻工人阶级男性。这些人开始逃兵。在2月10日，
so we're just less than two weeks after Homeni's return. Crowds of Homeni's supporters invade the police stations and barracks to find weapons. There are two prime ministers, remember. There's Bactear with his moustache and baza gan, moustache and goatee beard. Bactiard orders the army to restore order. So now the generals have to decide who to back. And on the next day, the 11th, which is remembered, remembered in Iran today is the moment the revolution basically reached its apotheosis.
所以我们距离霍梅尼回归还不到两周。霍梅尼的支持者人群入侵警察局和军营寻找武器。有两位总理，记住。有留着胡子的巴赫蒂亚尔和留着胡子和山羊胡的巴扎尔甘。巴赫蒂亚尔命令军队恢复秩序。所以现在将军们必须决定支持谁。在第二天，即11日，也就是今天在伊朗被记住的时刻，革命基本上达到了顶峰。
The army issued a statement. They said, we're going to stay neutral. All troops must remain in their barracks. And for Khomeini and his supporters, this was a massive victory, because they were now free to take over the ministries, the prisons, the police stations and the TV stations and so on. And there's an interesting moment here. On this day, the 11th, in chaos, a group of American military advisors were taken prisoner by the crowd. And basically, Ambassador Sullivan had to them out. And in the middle of all this, you got a call from the White House. And it was the Undersecretary of State. And he said, I've got a message for you from the National Security Advisor, Zimbigny of Prasinski. He wants you to organise an army coup against Khomeini. We've
军队发表了一份声明。他们说，我们将保持中立。所有部队必须留在军营里。对于霍梅尼和他的支持者来说，这是一场巨大的胜利，因为他们现在可以自由地接管各部委、监狱、警察局和电视台等等。这里有一个有趣的时刻。在这一天，11日，在混乱中，一群美国军事顾问被人群俘虏。基本上，沙利文大使不得不把他们弄出来。在所有这些中间，你接到了白宫的电话。那是副国务卿。他说，我有一个来自国家安全顾问兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基的消息。他想让你组织一场针对霍梅尼的军事政变。我们已经
realized, get the army to intervene now. And Sullivan said, are you joking? Like, the army have said they're going to stay neutral. And a load of our advisors have been captured, and I'm negotiating with Khomeini's meant to get them out. I'm not going to organise a coup now. And the Undersecretary of State said, he really, really wants you to focus on this coup. please get this coup done today. And Sullivan said, and Tabby, you'll have to bleak this out. Please tell Brasinski to f*** off.
意识到了，让军队现在干预。沙利文说，你在开玩笑吗？就像，军队已经说他们要保持中立。我们的一堆顾问被俘虏了，我正在和霍梅尼的人谈判让他们出来。我现在不会组织政变。副国务卿说，他真的，真的希望你专注于这场政变。请今天就把这场政变搞定。沙利文说，塔比，你得把这个消音。请告诉布热津斯基去死吧。
The Undersecretary of State said, that's not very helpful. And Sullivan said, oh, I'm sorry, would you like me to translate it into Polish for you? And then he slammed down the phone. So, Dominic, we've, I mean, we've listened to the rate,
副国务卿说，那没什么帮助。沙利文说，哦，我很抱歉，你想让我把它翻译成波兰语给你听吗？然后他重重地挂断了电话。所以，多米尼克，我们，我的意思是，我们听了那个速度，
you know, what's going on in Iran, with Charles gone, government's collapsed, Khomeini's followers are getting their hands on the levers of power. But what is going on in a moment? America at this point. So, as this would suggest, the Americans don't really have a clue what's going on. Until the end of 1978, most Americans had probably never, ever thought about Iran at all.
你知道，伊朗发生了什么，国王走了，政府崩溃了，霍梅尼的追随者正在掌握权力杠杆。但这一刻发生了什么？美国在这一点上。所以，正如这所暗示的，美国人真的不知道发生了什么。直到1978年底，大多数美国人可能根本从未想过伊朗。
The first time it really made front page news was when the Shah left, and most American papers said, oh, the Shah's left Iran. Well, he was useless and corrupt. Thank God he's gone. He should have gone earlier, if anything. But there are people within the kind of foreign policy establishment who are very alarmed. So Henry Kissinger, the Shah's old friend, Kissinger said, said, do-gooders and liberals and human rights people have undermined the Shah, and it's all their fault. This is classic Kissinger. And then Kissinger went on to say, you know, you can say what you like about the Shah going on, you order for Iran.
它真正成为头条新闻的第一次是国王离开时，大多数美国报纸说，哦，国王离开了伊朗。好吧，他没用而且腐败。感谢上帝他走了。如果说有什么的话，他应该早点走。但在外交政策机构内部有一些人非常惊慌。所以亨利·基辛格，国王的老朋友，基辛格说，行善者、自由派和人权人士破坏了国王，这都是他们的错。这是典型的基辛格。然后基辛格继续说，你知道，你可以说你想说的关于国王离开的事情，你为伊朗订购。
This is going to be a massive disaster. For us, for the Middle East, for the international order. I mean, you could say on this latter point, Kissinger's not entirely wrong, right? No, I mean, it's not rather tall. The other people who are very alarmed to US businesses. So some American businesses had invested very heavily in Iraq. Iran in the 1970s. I'll give an example.
这将是一场巨大的灾难。对我们，对中东，对国际秩序。我的意思是，你可以在后一点上说，基辛格并不完全错误，对吧？不，我的意思是，这并不太高。其他非常惊慌的人是美国企业。所以一些美国企业在伊拉克投资非常巨大。1970年代的伊朗。我举个例子。
The Starrett Housing Corporation. So that might not sound an exciting corporation. They were the people that had built the Empire State Building and they have just signed the contract to build Trump Tower. Imagine Trump Tower and Tehran. Well, they were going to build a housing complex on the edge of Tehran. Half a billion dollars the contract was worth. And they are now facing, if this revolution goes ahead and they lose the contract,
斯塔雷特住房公司。所以这听起来可能不是一个令人兴奋的公司。他们是建造帝国大厦的人，他们刚刚签署了建造特朗普大厦的合同。想象一下德黑兰的特朗普大厦。好吧，他们要在德黑兰边缘建造一个住宅区。合同价值五亿美元。他们现在面临着，如果这场革命继续进行，他们失去了合同，
they're facing massive losses. The list of companies, Gillette, Pepsi, Colgate, Coke, Johnson and Johnson, General Motors. All of these companies have got factories, they've got investments in Iran, they're going to lose a lot of money. So in the 50s, an Ayatollah had actually issued a fatwa against Pepsi. But that was because it was owned by a Baha'i industrialist. The franchise, the local franchise. The local franchise, yeah. Wow.
他们面临巨大的损失。公司名单，吉列、百事可乐、高露洁、可口可乐、强生、通用汽车。所有这些公司都有工厂，他们在伊朗有投资，他们会损失很多钱。所以在50年代，一位阿亚图拉实际上发布了针对百事可乐的教令。但那是因为它是由一位巴哈伊实业家拥有的。特许经营权，当地的特许经营权。当地的特许经营权，是的。哇。
I think not because he was particularly opposed to Pepsi per se. Yeah, these are going to be dark days for Pepsi drinkers in Iran, I think. in the early 1980s. The bigger issue, of course, for Americans is oil. Remember, Iran is the second biggest oil export in the world, but its production has been shut down since December. Prices are surging all the time because people are very worried
我想不是因为他特别反对百事可乐本身。是的，我认为这对伊朗的百事可乐饮用者来说将是黑暗的日子，在1980年代初。当然，对美国人来说更大的问题是石油。记住，伊朗是世界第二大石油出口国，但自12月以来其产量已经关闭。价格一直在飙升，因为人们非常担心
that this revolution is going to spread across the Middle East to other oil-producing countries. To Kuwait. There are articles in Western papers saying, it could spread to Saudi Arabia. Egypt could be the next country. Who knows? So in the next few weeks, the basic price for a barrel of crude oil went from $13 to $34.
这场革命会蔓延到中东其他产油国。到科威特。西方报纸上有文章说，它可能会蔓延到沙特阿拉伯。埃及可能是下一个国家。谁知道呢？所以在接下来的几周里，一桶原油的基本价格从13美元涨到了34美元。
And of course, it's that classic thing. You're an ordinary driver. You read in your newspaper that petrol prices are going to be shooting up. You think, well, I'm going to start filling my car. You know, I'm going to never let it go below three quarters full because I don't want to have to pay more for my petrol. So you get queues at pumps. The demand rises, the price rises. You get a massive inflationary spiral.
当然，这是经典的现象。你是一个普通的司机。你在报纸上读到汽油价格将要飙升。你心想，好吧，我要开始给我的车加油了。你知道，我永远不会让它低于四分之三满，因为我不想为我的汽油支付更多费用。所以你在加油站排队。需求上升，价格上升。你陷入了巨大的通货膨胀螺旋。
and for Carter, this is politically poisonous. Most Americans, let's be honest, they don't give a damn about Iran. I mean, it's not Vietnam. It wasn't in the newspapers year after year. When Carter runs for re-election in 1980, you know, Iran might come up, but it's not the thing if you're, you know, an ordinary housewife in Ohio, Iran isn't the first thing you think about. You do care about inflation, though.
对卡特来说，这在政治上是有毒的。老实说，大多数美国人根本不在乎伊朗。我的意思是，这不是越南。它没有年复一年地出现在报纸上。当卡特在1980年竞选连任时，你知道，伊朗可能会被提及，但如果你是俄亥俄州的一个普通家庭主妇，伊朗不是你首先想到的事情。不过，你确实关心通货膨胀。
You massively care about it. Even in 1978, the US inflation rate was 9%. Now, Carter had been confident he would get that down with interest rates, but he didn't expect an Iranian revolution. And actually, what happens, as a result, through the course of 1979, inflation doesn't come down. It goes up. 10%, 11%, 12% by October.
你非常关心它。即使在1978年，美国的通货膨胀率也是9%。现在，卡特曾自信他能通过利率将其降下来，但他没想到会发生伊朗革命。实际上，结果是，在1979年的过程中，通货膨胀并没有下降。它上升了。到10月达到10%、11%、12%。
No one expects the Iranian revolution. No one does. And if you open any American newspaper from 1979, it's full of people complaining about price rises. So John Updike wrote a book called Rabbit is Rich, one of his rabbit novels, set in 1979. He wrote it a couple of years later. And his everyman character in the rabbit novels, Harry Angstrom, is always whinging about inflation. I mean, he puts his money into South African Krugerans in the novel because he tells his wife this is a way to deal with their savings being eroded by inflation.
没有人预料到伊朗革命。没有人。如果你打开1979年的任何一份美国报纸，上面都充满了抱怨价格上涨的人。所以约翰·厄普代克写了一本名为《兔子富了》的书，他的一部兔子小说，背景设定在1979年。他几年后写的。他在兔子小说中的每一个普通角色，哈里·安斯特罗姆，总是抱怨通货膨胀。我的意思是，他在小说中把钱投入了南非克鲁格金币，因为他告诉他的妻子，这是应对他们的储蓄被通货膨胀侵蚀的一种方式。
He'd be a crypto dealer now. Exactly. He would. And we know from 2024 when Kamala Harris lost to Trump how much prices matter. You know, this is the classic bread and butter issue that American voters and all Western voters really care about. So, Dominic, this is a lesson from history. For those, you know, wondering who was going to win in the last election, you only had to study this period and you'd have known. So, Jimmy Carter, let's get to Jimmy Carter.
他现在会是个加密货币交易员。正是如此。他会是。我们从2024年卡马拉·哈里斯输给特朗普时知道价格有多重要。你知道，这是美国选民和所有西方选民真正关心的经典民生问题。所以，多米尼克，这是历史的教训。对于那些想知道谁会在上次选举中获胜的人，你只需要研究这段时期，你就会知道。所以，吉米·卡特，让我们谈谈吉米·卡特。
People will remember Jimmy Carter, he's basically 50% evangelical Sunday school teacher and 50% humorless policy wonk. kind of guy. Yeah. So basically, if you, Jimmy Carter, for his ideal evening, it's putting on his cardigan, TV addressed to the nation, unveiling a 73 point energy plan and telling everybody to turn the heating off and put on their hair shirts.
人们会记得吉米·卡特，他基本上是50%的福音派主日学校老师和50%不苟言笑的政策书呆子。那种人。是的。所以基本上，如果你，吉米·卡特，对于他理想的夜晚，是穿上他的开衫，向全国发表电视讲话，公布一项73点的能源计划，并告诉每个人关掉暖气，穿上他们的苦行衣。
And so that's what he does on the 5th of April on 1979. He goes on TV and he says to the American people, you're going to have to pay more for your gas. I would like you. I mean, this unbelievable in American, I mean, imagine this unimaginable, you can't conceive for a 21st century American president doing this.
所以这就是他在1979年4月5日所做的。他上电视对美国人民说，你们将不得不为你们的汽油支付更多费用。我希望你们。我的意思是，这在美国令人难以置信，我的意思是，想象一下，这不可想象，你无法想象21世纪的美国总统会这样做。
He says, I would like you to drive 15 miles a week fewer than you do now. At least once a week, take the bus, go by carpool. If you weren't close enough to home, walk. The thought of the commander and chief of the United States telling people to get the bus, this is not what they were used to hearing from John F. Kennedy or Richard Nixon. And obviously, if you live in quite a cold part of the United States, so in the northeast or the Midwest, where people use more oil and they're paying more for it, They don't want to hear this.
他说，我希望你们每周比现在少开15英里。至少每周一次，坐公共汽车，拼车。如果你离家不够近，就走路。美国三军统帅告诉人们去坐公共汽车的想法，这不是他们习惯从约翰·F·肯尼迪或理查德·尼克松那里听到的。显然，如果你住在相当寒冷的美国部分地区，比如东北部或中西部，那里的人使用更多的石油，他们支付更多的费用，他们不想听到这个。
They don't want to hear they have to pay more for their gas. And these bases already have a lot of working-class Democrats who are very Carter skeptic. So even at this point in the spring of 1979, a lot of liberal Democrats and sort of labor union bosses and things, so crucial to the Democratic Party, are saying, how the hell did we wind up with this bloke from the South?
他们不想听到他们必须为汽油支付更多费用。这些基地已经有很多对卡特非常怀疑的工人阶级民主党人。所以即使在1979年春天，许多自由派民主党人和工会老板之类的，对民主党至关重要的人，都在说，我们到底是怎么摊上这个南方来的家伙的？
This weird evangelical Christian who's telling us to turn the eating down. Like, we should get rid of him, get in Ted Kennedy. I know Ted Kennedy disgraced himself. Yeah, they're forgetting the whole drowning the woman thing. They're forgetting that. That's not a deal breaker anymore if he's going to get the petrol prices down. Now, get Kennedy in. And actually, in the next few weeks, things go from bad to worse.
这个奇怪的福音派基督徒告诉我们要关掉暖气。就像，我们应该摆脱他，让泰德·肯尼迪进来。我知道泰德·肯尼迪丢尽了脸。是的，他们忘记了淹死那个女人的整件事。他们忘记了那个。如果他能降低汽油价格，那就不再是交易破坏者了。现在，让肯尼迪进来。实际上，在接下来的几周里，情况变得越来越糟。
So by May, there are huge lines outside gas stations in Southern California. There was rationing in California. So basically, if you had a, if your kind of registration page, if your license pace of your car ended in an even number, you could go to the gas station on an even-numbered day. Was this under Governor Jerry Brown, whose nickname was Moonbeam? Yeah, Governor Jerry Brown. And now, my son mad, but actually lots of other states copied that, that rationing, even an odd-numbered days,
所以到了5月，南加州的加油站外排起了长队。加利福尼亚有配给。所以基本上，如果你的车牌号以偶数结尾，你可以在偶数日去加油站。这是在绰号为“月光”的州长杰里·布朗领导下吗？是的，州长杰里·布朗。现在，我儿子疯了，但实际上许多其他州也效仿了那种配给，奇数和偶数日，
because within weeks the gas stations are running out a petrol in New York and the mid-Atlantic states. And people start basically driving to other states to get their petrol. Wouldn't that use up all your petrol? Well, of course. So people are, so there are huge lines of cars everywhere. It's a complete shambles. Now, compared with what's been going on in Iran, this might not sound like a very big deal.
因为几周内，纽约和大西洋中部各州的加油站汽油就用完了。人们基本上开始开车去其他州加油。那不会用光你所有的汽油吗？好吧，当然。所以人们是，所以到处都是巨大的汽车队列。这完全是一团糟。现在，与伊朗发生的事情相比，这听起来可能不是什么大不了的事。
But in the context of 1970s America, when you consider that people are already very bruised after Vietnam and Watergate, this is really, really dangerous for Carter and his administration. And there are two elements of it, actually, that are very resonant today. So one of them is there are loads of conspiracy theories about all this. So polls show that eight out of ten Americans thought that somebody was controlled. all this. And they usually said it's corrupt Washington politicians, it's Arab oil shakes, it's bankers, probably in league with the British. It's always the British. So it's a kind of weird echo of Iranian conspiracy theories then. Yeah. Sort of paranoid resentments that are very deep-seated.
但在1970年代美国的背景下，当你考虑到人们在越南和水门事件后已经非常受伤时，这对卡特和他的政府来说真的非常非常危险。实际上，它有两个要素在今天非常有共鸣。所以其中之一是关于这一切有大量的阴谋论。所以民意调查显示，十分之八的美国人认为有人在控制这一切。他们通常说这是腐败的华盛顿政客，是阿拉伯石油酋长，是银行家，可能与英国人勾结。总是英国人。所以这是一种当时伊朗阴谋论的奇怪回声。是的。非常根深蒂固的偏执怨恨。
And then the other thing is nationalism. So you start seeing bumper stickers on cars, nuke their ass and take their gas. Or posters, people make posters showing GIs standing over kind dying Arabs with nuclear mushroom clouds in the background and the caption says, how much is the gas now? Did they not know that the Iranians are not Arabs? Well, I knew you'd be thinking that. So this crisis peaked on the weekend of the 23rd and 24th of June, 1979, by which point about two-thirds of the gas stations and Americans had closed and people were waiting sometimes
然后另一件事是民族主义。所以你开始在汽车上看到保险杠贴纸，“核平他们并拿走他们的汽油”。或者海报，人们制作海报，显示美国大兵站在垂死的阿拉伯人身上，背景是核蘑菇云，标题写着，“现在的汽油多少钱？”他们不知道伊朗人不是阿拉伯人吗？好吧，我知道你会这么想。所以这场危机在1979年6月23日和24日的周末达到顶峰，到那时大约三分之二的美国加油站已经关闭，人们有时在等待
days to get petrol. And in one place in particular, which becomes a symbol of this crisis, This turns into violence. This is Levitown, Pennsylvania. And it's so symbolic because this is your classic post-war planned suburban community. It was built by Levit and Sons for returning GIs after the Second World War, a symbol of the American dream, a symbol of their dependence on the car. There's rioting outside a service station.
排队加油。在一个特别的地方，这成为了这场危机的象征，演变成了暴力事件。这就是宾夕法尼亚州的莱维敦。它之所以具有象征意义，是因为这是典型的战后规划郊区社区。它是由莱维父子公司为二战后回国的退伍军人建造的，是美国梦的象征，也是他们对汽车依赖的象征。加油站外发生了骚乱。
It spreads. There are two days of riots. People looting shops, the post office setting cars on fire. The local officials have to declare a state of emergency. all of this kind of thing. You know, it's small beer compared with what's going on in Iran, but in the context of US politics,
骚乱蔓延开来。骚乱持续了两天。人们抢劫商店、邮局，焚烧汽车。当地官员不得不宣布进入紧急状态。诸如此类的事情。你知道，与伊朗正在发生的事情相比，这简直是小巫见大巫，但在美国政治的背景下，
it's a terrible look. And especially with an election coming up, well, an election in 1980 a year later. So what's Carter going to do? Carter has been planning a fifth nationwide address to the people about energy, but he decides to cancel it.
这看起来非常糟糕。特别是在选举即将到来的时候，也就是一年后的1980年大选。那么卡特会怎么做呢？卡特原本计划就能源问题向全国发表第五次演讲，但他决定取消。
And the reason that he cancels it is that his wife Rosalin and his opinion poll guru, who's a 29-year-old Wong, called Pat Cadell, have persuaded him that this is actually about something much bigger than petrol prices. Remember Carter is an evangelical Christian. And they say to him, the US is suffering from a deep spiritual malaise.
他取消演讲的原因是，他的妻子罗莎琳和他的民意调查专家——一位29岁的年轻人帕特·卡德尔——说服了他，这实际上比油价问题要严重得多。记住，卡特是一位福音派基督徒。他们对他说，美国正遭受着深刻的精神萎靡。
And you have been appointed by history, or indeed by God, to bring about the regeneration of the American people. So again, such a weird kind of distorted echo of what's happening in Iran. Right. Except I can't really see the Ayatollah doing what Carter does now. Carter goes into this sort of retreat, and he gets loads of trendy cultural theorists. people who were very well known in the 70s,
而你被历史，或者说是被上帝选中，来引领美国人民的复兴。所以，这又是一种与伊朗正在发生的事情极其怪异且扭曲的呼应。没错。但我实在无法想象阿亚图拉会做卡特现在做的事。卡特进入了一种隐居状态，他找来了许多时髦的文化理论家，那些在70年代非常出名，
kind of forgotten now, like Daniel Bell and Christopher Lash. These people who wrote these, you know, they would write articles in the New York Times about the cultural contradictions of capitalism or the New Age of Narcissism and all of this stuff, very fashionable in the 70s. Carter meets dozens of these people. I mean, dozens and dozens of them.
现在却被遗忘的人，比如丹尼尔·贝尔和克里斯托弗·拉什。这些人写过，你知道，他们会在《纽约时报》上撰写关于资本主义的文化矛盾或自恋新时代之类的文章，这些在70年代非常流行。卡特会见了数十位这样的人。我是说，几十个又几十个。
And he takes reams of notes. And he says, yes, this is absolutely right. I need to educate the American people, all of this kind of thing. His vice president, Walter Mondale, thought the Carter had lost his marbles and actually wanted to resign. He thought that this was a terrible idea. He had to be talked out of it.
他做了大量的笔记。他说，是的，这绝对正确。我需要教育美国人民，诸如此类。他的副总统沃尔特·蒙代尔认为卡特疯了，甚至想辞职。他认为这是一个糟糕的主意。他不得不被劝阻下来。
But finally, on the 15th of July, Carter, when he'd finished his sort of self-reeducation, he went on TV. He'd been secluded for 10 days writing this speech, and he goes on TV to address the American people. And he says, I know you're aware about oil prices, but we are suffering from a national crisis of confidence.
但最终，在7月15日，卡特在完成了他的自我再教育后，出现在电视上。他隐居了10天来撰写这篇演讲稿，然后他上电视向美国人民发表讲话。他说，我知道你们了解油价问题，但我们正遭受着一场全国性的信心危机。
Too many of us worship self-indulgence and consumption, but we've discovered that owning things and consuming things does not satisfy our longing for meaning. Piling up material goods cannot fill the emptiness of lives which have no confidence and no purpose. It's very Sunday school. It's very Sunday school and it's good stuff from a Sunday if you're in a Sunday school. Imagine you're a truck driver from Cleveland. Yeah, I can see that not going down well with that. Also, he begins the speech by listing all the things that people have been telling him why he's terrible.
我们中有太多人崇拜自我放纵和消费，但我们发现，拥有东西和消费东西并不能满足我们对意义的渴望。堆积物质财富无法填补那些没有信心和目标的生活的空虚。这非常像主日学。这非常像主日学，如果你在主日学里，这确实是好东西。想象一下你是一个来自克利夫兰的卡车司机。是的，我可以看出这不会受到欢迎。此外，他以列举人们告诉他的关于他为什么糟糕的事情作为演讲的开头。
Yeah. Which is not a great way, is it? He lists his own faults. I mean, yeah, this girl says I'm rubbish. This bloke says I'm terrible. I'm really odd. And then he says, you know, you probably want some practical things to do. You know, first of all, you should look into your hearts and stop being so consumerist.
是的。这可不是什么好方法，对吧？他列举了自己的缺点。我是说，是的，这个女孩说我很烂。那个家伙说我很糟糕。我真的很奇怪。然后他说，你知道，你们可能想要一些实际要做的事情。你知道，首先，你们应该审视自己的内心，停止如此消费主义。
And secondly, stop driving your car, take the bus, obey the speed limit, set your thermostats to save fuel, all this kind of thing. And then he ends with the Sunday school again. With God's help and the sake of our nation, it's time for us to join hands and commit ourselves. to a rebirth of the American spirit. I have to say, I cannot imagine Jim Callahan saying something like this to the British people in 1978. Maybe you should have done. He should have done, I think.
其次，停止开车，乘坐公交车，遵守限速，调低恒温器以节省燃料，诸如此类。最后，他又以主日学的内容结束。在上帝的帮助下，为了我们国家的利益，现在是我们携手并致力于美国精神复兴的时候了。我不得不说，我无法想象吉姆·卡拉汉在1978年对英国人民说这样的话。也许他应该这样做。我想他应该这样做。
Anyway, to the people watching this speech, 65 million people, this is bonkers. First of all, Americans are not used to being lectured about crisis of confidence, moral failings. They don't like downbeat speeches, do they? They like to be told everything's great. And if it's not, then it's the fault of other people. Correct.
总之，对于观看这场演讲的6500万人来说，这简直是疯了。首先，美国人习惯于被说教关于信心危机、道德缺陷。他们不喜欢消极的演讲，对吧？他们喜欢被告知一切都很棒。如果不是，那也是别人的错。没错。
For a US president to be denouncing consumerism is unheard of in the post-war era. I mean, it's unimaginable to think of JFK telling people off in 1962 for owning their enormous cars with tail fins and gigantic fridges the size of a house or something. And also Carter's spiritual themes, you know, presidents don't talk about this kind of thing. For him to be talking so earnestly about faith and rebirth and, you know, what life's all about and whatnot. I mean, this is mad stuff to a lot of people. But again, you know, I mean, Americans and Iranians are both, you know, they're getting lectures from moral leaders. Yeah, from spiritual leaders. And then Carter follows it up by purging his own administration.
对于一位美国总统来说，谴责消费主义在战后时代是闻所未闻的。我是说，无法想象肯尼迪在1962年责备人们拥有带有尾鳍的巨大汽车和像房子一样大的冰箱之类的东西。而且卡特的精神主题，你知道，总统们不会谈论这种事情。他如此真诚地谈论信仰、重生以及生活意义之类的东西。我是说，对很多人来说，这简直是疯话。但同样，你知道，我是说，美国人和伊朗人都在接受道德领袖的说教。是的，来自精神领袖。然后卡特接着清洗了他的政府。
So he sacks his treasury secretary, his attorney general, his energy secretary and so on. And at this point, people just think this blokes lost the plot. So the dollar plummets. His approval ratings go down to 23%. And this speech becomes, it's hung around his neck forever as a sign. of his perceived weirdness and failure. So it's called the malaise speech. And Tom, I know you're a big fan of The Simpsons.
所以他解雇了他的财政部长、司法部长、能源部长等等。在这一点上，人们只是认为这家伙疯了。于是美元暴跌。他的支持率降至23%。这场演讲被永远挂在他的脖子上，作为他被认为怪异和失败的标志。所以它被称为“萎靡演讲”。汤姆，我知道你是《辛普森一家》的忠实粉丝。
When a statue of Jimmy Carter is unveiled in Springfield, the place where The Simpsons is set, it is inscribed with the words, malaise forever. And people in the crowd are shouting, look, it's history's greatest monster, Jimmy Carter. Poor Jimmy. But worse is to come, isn't it?
当吉米·卡特的雕像在《辛普森一家》的背景地斯普林菲尔德揭幕时，上面刻着“永远萎靡”的字样。人群中有人喊道：“看，那是历史上最大的怪物，吉米·卡特。”可怜的吉米。但更糟糕的还在后面，不是吗？
Because we now move on, and we're approaching the moment that I'm sure all our listeners have been waiting for. The fishing trip to a swamp. So I think what's unprecedented now in the 20th century is the degree of contempt for Carter in the press corps and in the kind of Washington establishment. So you mentioned that he's starting to look very haggard. He's actually very fit because he's into jogging. And he does a run near Camp David.
因为我们现在继续前进，我们正在接近我相信所有听众都在等待的时刻。沼泽钓鱼之旅。所以我认为现在20世纪前所未有的是新闻界和华盛顿建制派对卡特的蔑视程度。所以你提到他开始看起来非常憔悴。他其实很健康，因为他喜欢慢跑。他在戴维营附近跑步。
There's a 10-K run and collapses, unfortunately. Do you know, I remember it so vividly on the front page of the newspapers. It was kind of when I was first starting to read newspapers and he just looked like, I always felt when I had to go on a run. I felt enormous sympathy and fellow feeling for him. He goes on this run and he looks like this tottering grey figure. He collapses and has to be held to his feet. And his press secretary, Jody Powell, said,
有一场10公里的跑步，不幸的是他晕倒了。你知道吗，我记得报纸头版上非常生动地报道了这件事。那是我刚开始读报纸的时候，他看起来就像，我每次不得不去跑步时都有的那种感觉。我对他产生了巨大的同情和共鸣。他去跑步，看起来像个摇摇欲坠的灰色身影。他晕倒了，不得不被人扶起来。他的新闻秘书乔迪·鲍威尔说，
if Carter had been set upon by a pack of wild dogs, the press would have sided with the dogs. And actually, is he then set upon by a wild animal? Is this what happens? Great. Come on. Tell us about this. But another dog.
如果卡特被一群野狗围攻，媒体会站在狗那边。事实上，他后来是不是被一只野生动物围攻了？是这样吗？太棒了。来吧。告诉我们这件事。但那是另一只狗。
So in August 1979, so a month later, the Washington Post broke the news with the excellent headline, rabbit attacks president. It's the biggest moment in 20th century, American history, isn't it? And to read the story, a killer rabbit attacked President Carter on a recent trip to Plains, Georgia, penetrating secret service security and forcing the chief executive to beat back the beast with a canoe paddle. The rabbit swam towards a canoe from which Carter was fishing in a pond. it was hissing menacingly. Its teeth flashing and nostrils flared and making straight for the president. So this rabbit, this aquatic killer rabbit,
所以1979年8月，也就是一个月后，《华盛顿邮报》以出色的标题“兔子袭击总统”打破了新闻。这是20世纪美国历史上最伟大的时刻，不是吗？读读这个故事，一只杀手兔在最近一次去佐治亚州平原镇的旅行中袭击了卡特总统，突破了特勤局的安保，迫使这位首席执行官用独木舟桨击退了野兽。兔子从卡特钓鱼的池塘里游向独木舟。它发出威胁的嘶嘶声。牙齿闪烁，鼻孔张开，直奔总统而来。所以这只兔子，这只水生杀手兔，
attacked Carter in a swamp. And the mad thing is what happened next, which is wildlife charities, attacks Carter. Now they said he shouldn't have hit the rabbit with a paddle. And Carter was forced to issue a statement, which he said, I didn't hit it. with a paddle. I just splashed water
在沼泽里袭击了卡特。疯狂的是接下来发生的事情，野生动物慈善机构攻击卡特。现在他们说他不应该用桨打兔子。卡特被迫发表声明，他说，我没有用桨打它。我只是泼水
towards it. Ladies gentlemen, the leader of the free world. To try to deter the rabbit. And at that point, when he said, oh, I didn't hit it with the battle, they were just splashed water. The Republicans, and indeed more hawkish Democrats said, okay, that's it. I'm finished with this guy.
向它。女士们先生们，自由世界的领袖。试图阻止那只兔子。就在那一刻，当他说，哦，我没有用桨打它，只是泼了水。共和党人，甚至更强硬的民主党人说，好吧，够了。我受够这家伙了。
What an absolute wimpy. He wouldn't even hit a rabbit. No wonder, we are losing Iran. And actually, this takes us back to Iran, finally, from the rabbit. So in the last few months, while the Americans have been going mad. What's been going on in Iran? The streets have been taken over by various paramilitary groups loyal to Khomeini, to the Islamic Revolutionary Guard, most famously. Revolutionary courts
真是个懦夫。他甚至不愿打一只兔子。难怪我们正在失去伊朗。事实上，这最终把我们从兔子带回了伊朗。所以在过去的几个月里，当美国人变得疯狂时。伊朗发生了什么？街道被忠于霍梅尼的各种准军事组织所接管，最著名的是伊斯兰革命卫队。革命法庭
have been set up under Sharia law. They have been holding trials in secret. They have been executing officials who are loyal to the Shah. They have started to reverse what they see as symbols of westernization, most obviously women's rights. So they brought back the veil. By spring of 1979, women have already lost some of their divorce and child custody rights, though not interestingly, the right to vote. There are new censorship laws, so liberal newspapers have been shut down, and Iran has adopted its new constitution, which explicitly pledges to export the revolution and unite the entire Islamic world.
在伊斯兰教法下成立。他们一直在秘密进行审判。他们一直在处决忠于沙阿的官员。他们已经开始扭转他们所认为的西方化象征，最明显的是妇女权利。所以他们带回了面纱。到1979年春天，妇女已经失去了一些离婚和子女监护权，尽管有趣的是，没有失去投票权。有新的审查法，所以自由派报纸被关闭，伊朗通过了新宪法，明确承诺输出革命并团结整个伊斯兰世界。
So it's kind of Trotskyite Islamism. Exactly so. But for Khomeini's supporters, the struggle is not over. as so often in revolutions they are very anxious about enemies without and within and by the late summer of 1979 so precisely the point when Jimmy Carter is giving his
所以这是一种托洛茨基式的伊斯兰主义。正是如此。但对于霍梅尼的支持者来说，斗争还没有结束。正如革命中经常发生的那样，他们对内外的敌人非常焦虑，到了1979年夏末，也就是吉米·卡特发表
sort of breast beating speeches they are focused on two threats in particular first of all the Shah the Shah has not gone away he has not yet gone to the United States he's been wandering the earth as we will discover next time from Morocco to Mexico and of course the Shah still sees
那种捶胸顿足的演讲时，他们特别关注两个威胁，首先是沙阿，沙阿并没有消失，他还没有去美国，正如我们下次会发现的那样，他一直在从摩洛哥到墨西哥的地球上流浪，当然沙阿仍然认为
himself as the rightful emperor of Iran and he still has people who support him. And secondly, Khomeini's supporters are becoming fixated on something in the heart of Tehran, the ultimate symbol of Western imperialism, the place they call the den of spies, the place from which the CIA,
自己是伊朗合法的皇帝，他仍然有支持他的人。其次，霍梅尼的支持者开始专注于德黑兰中心地带的某个东西，那是西方帝国主义的终极象征，他们称之为“间谍巢穴”的地方，也就是中央情报局认为
they believe, plotted its coup in 1953 and might do again, the United States Embassy. And even as Jimmy Carter is fending off accusations that he hit this, rabbit with a paddle, a group of Iranian students are meeting to discuss what they're going to do about the U.S. Embassy. And what follows is the defining episode in the Iranian Revolution
他们在1953年策划政变并可能再次策划的地方，即美国大使馆。就在吉米·卡特还在抵御关于他用桨打了那只兔子的指控时，一群伊朗学生正在开会讨论他们要对美国大使馆做什么。接下来发生的事情是伊朗革命的决定性事件，
and one of the greatest humiliations in American history. Well, thank you, Dominic, really set up for, as you say, I mean, just one of the defining moments of 20th century history. And our rest of history club members can hear the next two episodes in the series. So that is the story of the seizure of the U.S. Embassy, which will be in the next. next episode and then the final episode which will be about Jimmy Carter's disastrous attempt to rescue the hostages being held in Tehran right now. If you want to join the club, then please do so at the rest ishistory.com. But for now, goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也是美国历史上最大的耻辱之一。好吧，谢谢你，多米尼克，正如你所说，这确实为20世纪历史上最具决定性的时刻之一做了铺垫。我们的“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员可以收听该系列的接下来两集。这就是占领美国大使馆的故事，将在下一集播出，然后是最后一集，关于吉米·卡特试图营救目前被扣押在德黑兰的人质的灾难性尝试。如果你想加入俱乐部，请访问therestis-history.com。但现在，再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。